Joe Biden gave a speech today on this j6
eve where he said I kid you not that we
almost lost this country over January 6
and my response immediate was like wow
if a thousand dudes who are unarmed
riding at a government building is
enough to destroy this nation we're
going to have to cancel all of our
Foreign Wars and foreign funding because
we are we are much too weak to be
involved in any kind of War if a
thousand unarmed dudes riding at the
capital is going to destroy the fabric
of this nation of course Joe Biden's
full of it and it's not true but this is
his his play I guess January 6 is
tomorrow it's the anniversary and uh
this is his big uh his his his pitch to
the American people as to why we should
vote for him again I guess you know I
got I got to say it's actually quite
remarkable because I remember all the
other campaigns where they'd say
something like John McCain is bad on
taxes and bad on America and it's like
taxes that was the issue now you got Joe
Biden making videos where he says half
this country is evil and wants to kill
you and it's like oh that's a heck of a
p a campaign strategy so we'll talk
about that and I got to be honest there
there are a bunch of really great and
important news stories but I'm going to
say this one instead
aliens cuz in Miami NBC news reports
aliens okay so here's what happened some
kids were fighting with sticks and
fireworks people reported as gunshots
the police show up and then for some
reason online people claimed that 8ot
tall Shadow alien beings were being shot
at and NBC picked the story up of course
they call they they actually put in the
headline LOL but uh it's Friday so we're
gonna we're going to have fun we'll talk
about all this stuff before we get
started my friends head over to cast
brew.com to buy cast Brew Coffee why
because it is the best dang coffee
you'll ever have Appalachia kns is so
good whole bean sold out but we are
about to get a a new stock of the whole
bean Appalachia nights ground coffee
still available and of course everyone's
favorite rise with Roberto Jr we got
decaf we got decaf sleepy Joe I got to
tell you it's a great gift for your
friends and family to buy them a bag of
sleepy Joe coffee because it's funny
it's hilarious we also got K Cups if you
want to support the show you go to
casper.com you buy coffee because we
sponsor ourselves and this is our coffee
company we are also working on our
coffee shops the work is happening trust
me the equipment is in and uh it it's
looking now like I know everyone's going
to Gran when they hear this we we we got
contractors we're going over the
paperwork April by April we should have
this beautiful and amazing coffee shop
up up and ready and I trust these guys
because they finished our new studio
already so the new studio is done all we
have to do I should say the the
construction is done now we're waiting
for technical work but these guys are
also like we're going to get your coffee
shop done it'll be done by April it's
going to be huge support us and uh get
involved if you'd like but also head
over to
timcast.net only to the Iowa caucus show
on January 15th in Iowa in De Mo we will
have live audience seats very small
amount I think it's only 50 and we're
probably we're probably going to sell
out in 10 minutes from now but you're
going to be hanging out up close and
personal with the crew it we got
security everything's going to be great
we're going to have a rotating group of
people from the caucus different
political campaigns hanging out
explaining what's going on as we talk
about this it'll probably be an extended
show and it's and I got to tell you it's
not so much that buying tickets to an
event you're you're this is this is not
so much like an auditorium event where
you're sitting in a chair in front of a
stage this is more like you are coming
into a building with everyone to hang
out during the Iowa caucus that's why
there's very few tickets we're taking
security very seriously and it's why
they're a bit more expensive but become
a member at Tim cast.com if you want to
support us you want to buy those tickets
smash the like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
joining us tonight to talk about this
and a whole lot more is representative
Alex Mooney hey great to be with you
great to be with you um so we you're a
member of Congress yeah yeah represent
West Virginia half the state 27 counties
District number two but it's a half to
say most of my colleagues they're
Congressman there's one of 10 they
represent maybe 10% of the state but in
my case I pleasure of representing half
the state and they changed around the
districts last cycle I've actually
represented two-thirds of the state wow
so that's great so uh you're our rep for
we're not we're not currently at our
West Virginia Studio yet because it's
being built but uh for where I live and
for where we're setting up everything
you will you will be our rep and uh but
you're also you're running for the
Senate running for the Senate Republican
primary May May 14th Joe Joe Mansion has
chosen to retire everyone seen that good
everyone I I think he knew he couldn't
win anyway so and there there's no other
Democrat that's of any credibility that
anybody can think of that could run so
most people are well aware this is 100%
whoever wins the Republican primary is
is going to win the general election
yeah yeah absolutely when uh when we
were first moving to the area uh
Cassandra Fairbanks uh now Cassandra
McDonald she was like we got to find a
way to get this guy in the show you're
going to love me he's like Ron Paul and
I was like really she like yeah he wants
the gold standard I do want the gold
standard yeah I was like all right cool
so we finally got you here so uh and you
also have a bunch of resolutions have
the bill on the gold standard I wasn't
sure what was going to come up on the
show so house resolution 2435 you can
look it up because I'm an elected
official I'm my 10th year in Congress
and then a lot of people running for
office say what they're going to do what
they promise to do in the future I'd
like to talk about what I've actually
done what what I've actually shown to do
put in I'm the first Congressman put in
the bill to return our country to the
gold standard since Jack Kemp in in the
1980s but I'm good company Ronald Reagan
was for it uh Donald Trump said he was
supportive uh Ted Cruz many others so it
is a good thing to do I've done my
research and you know we're looking at
inflation today and all the games played
with montary policy and the fed and so
much government intervention in the free
market in so many ways returning to Gold
Standard we get that under control this
going to be fun you got a bunch of other
bills too but we'll talk about all this
thanks for hanging out you be fun we got
Carter Banks hanging out up everyone
Carter Banks here all things music at uh
timcast and trash house I'm just hanging
out showing off this bandana that
Jessica made me oh cool so yeah we got
Phil as well hello everybody my name is
Phil abon uh lead singer of the heavy
metal band All That Remains failed
musician anti-communist
counterrevolutionary Serge yes I'm here
uh I wanted to shout out Su and Tai guy
thanks for this record man I appreciate
the record a lot looks like the old
tracks records from Chicago um and the
shirt as well and the the record has has
great Vibes it emanates great Vibes I'm
behind the chachki array here so I'm I'm
picking up the I think yeah anyways
let's it we got the story from the post
millennial breaking Biden targets
president Trump quote Maga extremists in
unhinged angry Valley Forge speech
before leaving the stage Biden yelled
out I understand power I just I just
this dude I'm sorry man Joe Biden is
just not with it okay he he is old he is
incomprehensible and the idea that he
could hold this position is laughable
but of course there are a lot there are
a lot of people that want him to have
this position to be fair that number is
dwindling every single day way that
story yesterday where his volunteers are
quitting in droves but let's uh let's
start by playing this clip from
C-SPAN because you know sometimes I you
I don't know if I would use the word
unhinged as liberally as say like the
post-millennial would but I have to
agree with him at least here because
when Joe Biden says we almost lost our
country over January 6 I'm like
unhinged absolutely detached from
reality after January 6 one of the first
things I said was guys it's not the
1600s anymore you can't seize control of
a government by standing in a building
but Joe Biden apparently thinks it is
because he's probably old enough to
remember but here's the clip let's play
it I just visited the grounds of Aly
Forge I've been there a number of times
since the time I Was A Boy Scout years
ago you know it's the very site that I
think every American should visit
because it tells the story of the pain
and the suffering and the true
patriotism it took to make
America Today We Gather in a New Year
some 246 years later just one day before
January
6 a date forever shared in our memory
because it was on that day that we
nearly lost
America lost it all today we're here to
answer the most important of questions
is democracy still America's sacred
cause no it was never I don't think it
ever
was this is not rhetorical academic or
hypothetical where the democracy is
still America's sacred cause is the most
urgent question of our time he's correct
well he's he's correct see the the
parasitic woke individuals who are
trying to displace the American
constitutional republic with their
Multicultural democracy are terrified
that those who believe in the
constitutional republic and the vision
of the founding fathers they're they're
terrified that uh we're winning and so
when Joe Biden gets up there and says
our democracy you need to understand
he's not talking about you guys because
yeah when when we sit here and say this
country has never been a democracy he
clearly isn't talking to us during this
was really fascinating during the co
lockdowns when you saw Ronda santis
releasing relieving the the the the lock
pressure when you chrisy know she didn't
lock down South Dakota Joe Biden made a
statement about how we are all doing
this thing how we must do this we are
doing this and I noticed something real
interesting I said that's fascinating
because the red States aren't doing this
only the blue states are so when Joe
Biden addresses the nation and says what
we are doing he's explicitly saying I am
not talking to you Republicans and when
he does this it's the exact same message
it's uh it's actually a maist or or it
hearkens back to Mau ISM um when ma
would talk about the the Communists he
would talk about their democracy and he
would talk about uh you know the Chinese
people and stuff but he was only talking
about people that shared his political
perspective James Lindsay has a great
and I know I bring up James Lindsay a
lot but James Lindsay has a great uh
podcast on this that goes through one of
Mao's speeches and actually Compares it
to one of Joe Biden speeches and I will
find it and post it on my Twitter
account but it's it's what they do they
they constantly like they exclude
intentionally with language that sounds
inclusive but essentially if you are not
thought of as or if you're not in their
in group you're thought of as an as not
a whole person that's one of the things
that ma said if you weren't a communist
you didn't have a soul like it they
really looked at it like almost a
spiritual thing so um it doesn't
surprise me it doesn't do anything that
he said he was going to do when it comes
to trying to bring the us together so
reminds me like when they said not my
president but like an inversion of that
like not my people yeah almost yeah I
like when I talk to children in
particular I say what former government
you say let's say the Pledge of
Allegiance pledge allegiance to the flag
the United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands right there
in the Pledge of Allegiance and when
these liberals come up and say democracy
and ignore that we're a republic with
constitutional laws and rights it's as
if they think they can just whatever
they feel like make it the law even it
totally tramples your rights as an
individual and freedoms it's not our
government I think that that's uh I
think that the the attempt to adjust
language and meanings of words is
actually or what it boils down to is an
attempt to circumvent the law because if
they can convince you that the words
contained in a piece of legislation
don't mean what they plainly mean what
they plainly what you would plainly
understand them to mean then the whole
meaning of the Law changes that's one of
the things again that you hear you hear
uh land dedications often and those
should be completely and totally uh off
limits because what it does is it plants
the seed of illegitimacy of the United
States that means that the the land that
you're on whoever owns it they acquired
it illegitimately that means that the
government can take it because you're
not protected by the Fourth Amendment
for illegitimately acquired lands and
those kind of twisting of meanings is
what the left does constantly they've
been doing it and if people want to
argue and say no right now we are
literally in the United States arguing
over what a woman is they they they
Democrats the corporate press they're
very good at controlling the debate
itself and and pulling you away from
arguing about what you want into arguing
on their terms so instead of arguing why
we should get rid of gun gun control
we're arguing to what degree we accept
gun control and to be fair it is
Republicans in the past who have been in
favor of gun control too yes but where
we are now the people who claim that
we're a democracy are the people who
think that they can simply get together
and if there are more more of them than
you they can decide to vote and you no
longer have rights that's not how a
republic Works a democracy is two wolves
in a lamb deciding what's for lunch the
Republic is a well-armed lamb contesting
the vote that's I believe I'm probably
uh I'm probably not getting it
absolutely correctly but I believe
Benjamin Franklin said that that's the
point the Wolves can vote whatever they
want you have a right to live they can't
just vote to eat you yeah but the way
these people view it as look there
there's a reason why Joe Biden is it is
it is it is unambiguous is facilitating
illegal immigration into this country on
a mass scale colluding with human
traffickers and he is his administration
explicitly smuggling children in the
dead of night on these planes and faster
and more than ever and it's because
their their their mentality is if you if
the population of a country doesn't
agree with you import a different one
and the other way you say democracy it's
mob rule yeah if you have 51% of the
vote you can take away the rights of the
other 49% and take the thing like free
speech I never thought you know in my
last four years in Congress when
Democrats had total control that they
really thought they could throw people
off the internet I mean when they threw
Donald Trump off Twitter for example you
know you think if you can throw the
president off do you think the rest of
Americans won't be thrown off the social
media if they if the left or the owners
think it's something you just say
something you disagree with and the
think that they can tell us what we can
say and what we can even think and I'm
telling you I've seen it man in Congress
I've seen them put that stuff in the
witch investigations where the rule of
law has been applied one way for
Republicans another way for Democrats it
is scary and and you mentioned you know
anti-communist my mother fled a
communist country she was born and
raised in Cuba okay and she came here
when she was 20 to live in Freedom as
have many other immigrants who've come
here legally and to see the left in this
country act that way that we're not a
republic it's whatever they want they
can do to us it is scary and it is it is
as scary as your listeners might think
if not more so what I've actually seen
Michael M makes the excellent point it
is it it it is much much it can be much
much worse than you think yeah people
don't realize what bad is yeah and so
they hear these stories about communism
and it's just
like the typical thing you hear about
what communist countries do is the light
side of how bad it gets yeah today uh
shout out to the punk rock NBA on
Twitter he is a YouTuber his name is
Finn mckeny made a uh uh you a video
about uh the breakup of um Rage Against
and he was rightly critical of the of
the band using communist imagery it's
it's unacceptable uh it's it's like
using Nazi IM imagery Communists killed
millions and millions and millions of
people there's a reason why I say every
day that I'm that I'm on the show that
I'm an anti-communist
counterrevolutionary because that's an
actual like there are people in the
United States Congress that are in the
DSA the DSA constantly tweets supportive
messages about Marx they tweet
supportive messages about Lenin like
this is not a joke you know and you
bring it up to people the the they're so
quick to say that we have a right-wing
problem in the United States to the
point where the right is almost just the
the concept of the right is synonymous
with bad and that's just so detached
from reality you can look at the right
and say there are there are bad things
that have been done from people on the
right or bad ideas that have come from
the right fine but to to think that an
ENT entire
philosophy because right now on the
right is where the enlightenment lives
right like all of your romantic
philosophies like like socialism is a
romantic philosophy it's based in the
idea that that you can Will things into
existence as opposed to reason you know
like the like the Enlightenment and the
idea that this stuff is acceptable it's
just it's it's so bad for the country
and it will cause massive problems and
we're starting to see them it's bad for
the world yeah 100% absolutely yeah it's
failed everywhere it's been tried why do
we need to try it again yep I mean I
they're not going to stop trying I can
go on and on about this you see that
same here man that Meme where that uh
what was that woman she's like from Al
jaer Plus or whatever and she says you
know just because socialism hasn't been
implemented properly doesn't mean we
just give up yeah sometimes when you you
you got to break some eggs or whatever
and then someone responds with oops I
burn this a and it shows The Killing
Fields or whatever like dude nobody
knows about all these things that
happened they only know about like the
right stuff and they don't realize
socialism is a road to Communism the
whole point I I was talking over the
holidays with people and everyone's
heard of the right-wing Boogeyman Joe
Biden giving the speech
like and I'm talking to people I'm like
did you know that in 2020 we saw the
worst rights the country seen in five
decades it was the left did you know
that on May 29th 2020 thousands of
far-left extremists firebombed the White
House setting fire to a guard poost
setting fire to St John's Church the
historical church across the street uh
70 plus police officers were injured in
the scuffle and the president was forced
into an emergency bunker they go what
we've had people on this show we Marian
Williamson I asked her and she's like I
don't know what happened with what are
you talking about it's like how do you
not know what is happening in your
backyard look Mar Williamson is a very
very nice lady and she is more deserving
of being president than Joe Biden and
any other Democrat running for the
Democrats but I got to be honest if you
don't know that the house you are
seeking to occupy was firebombed only a
couple years ago I'm not sure you're fit
for the
job it's something you should know they
call them mostly peaceful protests when
when they do it when they were burning
down a police station burn down police
station which which you like young
people don't realize it but I mean I'm
probably your age you're probably my age
like back in the 80s these kinds of of
of phrases we were familiar with because
we would watch show I watched a bunch of
shows about you know about Russia about
a lot of stuff about uh East Germany
there was this this one show about
paintball like these kids that used to
play paintball and they got mixed up
with spies in East Germany it was super
cool but the point is like you would
hear how in these in communist countries
and and in socialist countries how
phrases would be said and everybody was
aware that they did not mean what they
said like the words that they were
saying and the meaning behind the words
were totally in congruous in it's like
what we saw with VI ramaswami gets
questioned by that Washington postom and
she says will you condemn white
supremacy and he's like I condemn all
forms of racial discrimination and it's
because white supremacy to the left
means something different than what it
actually means they they they have their
own different
language it's it's fascinating they use
words to that to them mean something but
to US mean something different on
purpose to trick us and to trick the
ignorant and so when V gramas Swami gets
interviewed by those two and by that
Dasha burn or whatever her name is it's
one of the most dis like just yo that
lady needs to be fired but I understand
NBC is not is not a news organization
they're an activist organization so why
would they fire their prosers but this
woman Dasha is not interviewing a
presidential candidate she's berating
someone over her personal emotional
activist cause and V accurately points
out the issue with white supremacy is
that they defund it as punctuality and
like a an hour-based work schedule so is
I need to is that what you want me to
condemn and she's just interrupting him
non-stop it's fascinating when VI is on
the CNN Town Hall debate stage they
always have to interrupt because they're
not journalists yeah they're not here to
say tell me your thoughts on issue
they're here to say here's what you're
supposed to think on issue shut your
mouth yeah just like it reminds me of
the Trump CNN Town Hall thing every time
just like they would ask him stuff and
he would give an answer and then they
would just she would correct him with
incorrect stuff it's just shocking to me
again I bring up you know people that
are that you know lived through that
were alive when when communist countries
were were prevalent when they were like
during the Cold War and it's like why is
it that I know there are people in
Congress that are that are old enough to
remember why are they unaware why is it
that none of the the republicans in
Congress actually will call out the the
anyone on the squad and be like why are
you associating with the DSA when the
DSA is tweeting lenning quotes why are
you associating with them why do you
caucus with them why is that acceptable
and and I mean like you guys should I
wish that you guys would do it because
this should you should be
absolutely shamed into into a a cave if
you sit there and walk around with your
with with a sickle and Hammer or if
you're you're quoting marks and I mean
not to not to you know go back to the
whole like Rage Against the Machine
thing but the guy's got a pedal that has
a Lenin quote on it like sometimes
history needs a push the P was a million
was 100 million on the it's a it's a
it's a foot pedal made by Dunlop it's a
it's his W pedal on the side of it I
gotta just you could buy that from from
Dunlop yeah Jim dun yeah Dunlop company
they have a it's it's on the side of you
can you can go to the website buy a
pedal that has that quote on it I will
bring up the picture my friend yes you
can absolutely and it says that's wild
it says uh yeah the sometimes history
needs a push and that push like I said
that pushes a 100 million dead people so
so let's clarify real quick this is a a
guit car pedal available from Dunlap
Corporation the Dunlap company that you
can go and buy right now with a l quot
on it that says sometimes history needs
a push yes everyone should email that
company asking why they are calling for
the genocide against
people I can't think of any more clear
way to put it than that I mean yeah
let's let's let's play the game contact
them and
say so this is like the
signature sometimes history needs a push
it's got a communist St the red star on
it and it's you know on the side it says
uh yeah I just retweeted it it's on my
it's on the top of my yeah how about how
about uh everybody reach out to Dunlop
and ask them why they're selling
genocidal uh calling for genocide why
are they're supporting genocide and and
then see what they say this kind of
stuff the fact that we accept this as a
society is is because we have a redhed
redw washed educational system that's
that's Dunlop you say huh what do I got
here done with Dunlop this is a Fender
guitar pick there you go I will not use
Dunlop guitar picks anymore I used to
use tortex those were the ones not
anymore that's done Lop yeah the tort
the jazz tortex jazz the purple Jazz 3s
no longer when you talk about my age in
the history I me I graduated high school
in 89 went off to college and there's a
class on the Soviet Union and part of
the theme of the class was how that
Soviet Union was there to stay we have
to learn to work with them and they're
never going to go away except that it
went away that year they had to cancel
the class because the Soviet Union fell
apart completely because communism
doesn't work socialism doesn't work even
that guy Joe bid was head of Foreign
Affairs committee at the time and was
one of the leading proponents of working
with the Soviet Union accepting them as
an equal don't fight them really was he
yeah yeah he he him a bunch of lefties
were hey we can't fight these guys I
guess they didn't have a problem with
them I don't know but they were you know
they had the view that that Soviet Union
was a workable economy and it was
powerful and it was fine and we just got
to accept them and the Republicans
didn't believe that I mean some did some
didn't but they CR they got crushed and
so they fell apart cuz it doesn't work I
don't think they you push thing sorry I
don't think they knew about the ggs yet
no who oh back when they said that
probably yeah well well the countries
within there you know Poland they were
fighting for Freedom right they were
they were believing in the right to have
property and things and the stuff they
had before they got taken over by the
Communists and and they underestimated
that and frankly threw him under the bus
saying that Soviet Union would never you
know dissolve it dissolved and it do you
know so people didn't think yeah people
really that was kind of the general
consensus though like mhm it was
information didn't travel the way that
it does now and back then like you
didn't think that the Soviet Union was
going to fall the day before it fell
which it it was on the it was it was
it's on December 26th in case anyone
wants to celebrate it with me every year
I uh should should the Brin wall goes
down yeah you know but it was the end of
the Soviet Union but yeah like here
let's let's show this real quick this is
uh I just I just Google searched it
there a website called George's Music I
wouldn't recommend anyone contacting
just like a small distributor like a
small store whatever but here's
sometimes history needs a push and that
is the was it the crybaby W Tom Morell
pedal and uh here you can see from
brainy quote Vladimir Lenin sometimes
history needs a push so why don't we ask
Dunlop why it is that I mean that quote
is specifically a call for genocide yeah
historically it's a call for genocide
because the the push is millions dead
the point was that there are people who
are resistant to your your changes and
if you're on the right side of History
you have to push against them and what
was that push they killed 100 million
people in the history of
Communism so uh no no Dunlop yeah that's
Pro bolik no thanks yeah I I it's
frustrating it's frustrating as hell um
I mean I called out like I was making a
stink about this when uh uh what was his
name Speaker Ryan used a it talked about
Rage Against the Machine it was like
2012 okay when when Ryan was speaker and
I I called out uh you know I was like oh
blah blah blah cuz he talked about you
coming out to rage against machine or
something like that and uh coming out to
them what he was walking out like you I
thought he was gay I was like no I mean
well Ryan you know speak of Ryan maybe
but either way um he uh he was he caught
some crap from from uh the guys in Rage
and I wrote up a uh an opad they I think
they ran it in AP um but yeah on behalf
of the machine no I was like you're a
commi what are you talking about you
know and I was like you you can't sit
there and talk talk about Republicans
being bad when you're a lital literal
communist because there's it's no
comparison any liberal as much as the
the Communists online want to you know
swear up and down that that capitalism
actually kills millions of people and
blah blah blah any liberal should
understand that a liberal Society is far
and a way better than a communist
society and you should be able to
vocally explain why and that's you
should be able to do that you should be
taught that stuff in school and now
we've got you know LGBT studies in
school and stuff communism couldn't
exist without capitalism exact in the
first place so all it really is is just
taking everyone back down till it fails
and then everyone has to start over from
scratch it's yeah I mean Perpetual marks
go marks knew that Marx knew that like
the way Marx looked at it was like
there's stages of history and he thought
that Comm like capitalism was going to
get so successful and so abundant that
it would you'd be able to have socialism
and and it would be steps in in uh in
history or whatever but we got uh we got
more big news we'll segue out of this
one from the Independent Supreme Court
will decide if Trump can be kept off
2024 ballots after January 6
Insurrection I love how they just they
make an affirmative statement in the
headline despite the fact the headline
is literally the Supreme Court will
decide if there's actually any question
of the Insurrection in the 14th
Amendment because the argument is if
Trump did engage an Insurrection then
the 14th Amendment would keep him off
however well actually that's not fair
that's not fair the 40 Amendment likely
uh uh doesn't even apply to the
president and we haven't even Trump
hasn't even been charged with any kind
of insurrection so we're nowhere near
there but of course the independent is
going to affirmatively state in the
headline after it already happened but
anyway that's why I used this Source
because you know we love our leftist
friends the reality is the Supreme Court
has granted CCH to Donald Trump he will
go to the Supreme Court and have his
argument the Supreme Court will listen
to the argument as to whether or not
Trump can be removed from these ballots
this could end the uh the issue once in
for all so I hope they answer this
really really quickly I don't know when
they're expected to come into session
but uh you know there's a slim chance
the Supreme Court comes out and says
actually yes Trump did engage an
Insurrection and so he's off the ballot
and it pulls him off the ballot
everywhere not really going to happen
but that you know look the the the
reason roie Wade got overturned it's
court is because a group I think it was
Mississippi right where they filed the
lawsuit Mississippi was they sued
because Mississippi was set a ban an
abortion and so they sued saying hey you
can't do this and the Supreme Court said
not only can they roie weight's gone
everybody so if they just did not
challenge it and let Mississippi do what
they wanted roie Wade would still be
there yeah they lost at all so there's a
possibility could backfire but I really
do think Supreme Court's going to side
with Trump on this one yeah I think
it'll backfire actually goes back to we
talking about back I didn't go backfire
yeah I think the court I think the
Court's just going to say you can't do
that you guys are you guys can't be
throwing presidential cand no no I meant
backfire on Trump no no I think backfire
on the lefties know backfire in the
sense that that uh the states that are
meddling around I mean Colorado is not
as much of a Target State Maine has the
one congressional district that
sometimes goes goes for Republicans but
goes back to what we're saying about the
Communist in this country we're not
communist therefore we're innocent until
proven guilty people have heard of that
innocent until proven guilty president
Trump has convict been convicted of
absolutely nothing he's not been charged
he haven't been charged that much that's
convicted so therefore he's an innocent
man under the rule of law nobody has
been charged with with Insurrection have
they conspiracy to commit I think is
conspiracy okay I think it was
conspiracy to commit it not actually
committing it okay they were clever with
that but but nonetheless we're talking
about President Trump on the ballot he's
convicted of absolutely nothing and
these are people who claim to be for the
people like really so if an innocent man
because you're innocent proven guilty
can be thrown off ballots because you
don't like him or because you think he
may have done something I mean this is
this is uh basically chaos what about
what about Santos yeah same thing same
thing nothing either yeah and he got he
got that's crazy infuriating but Mendes
gets to stay with gold bars and pockets
in his in his how has he not been
expelled yeah they didn't they just
issue a sueding indictment I do not know
like oh we got more on this guy yeah
there's a lot Santos has been accused of
a lot of things but he's he's not been
convicted of anything and he gets that's
crazy he's guilty of being awesome the
only two people we ever thrown out
before we actually convicted of
something so that's a different standard
but the reason that it happened is
because he is because Republicans are
stupid and because Democrats are crafty
Democrats are more than happy to vote
with Le and I was there voting less than
half the Republicans voted for that
interestingly enough the new speaker of
the house uh Mike Johnson uh the
majority leader Steve scales the
majority whip and the everyone in
leadership voted against removing him
against removing him as did most
Republicans but the Committee reported
it out nonetheless overriding leers W
yeah so I mean Kevin McCarthy is want
who set the committee he he resigned now
but the new speaker Mike Johnson voted
against it I don't know how Kevin would
have you know I don't and so basically
what was it how many Republicans ended
up voting it ended up being like 111
voted no to expel him including me and
about 90 or so voted yes to expel them
so the minority of the Republicans but
every Democrat I think one abstained but
basically every Democrat was more than
happy to throw him out everyone like I
can't imagine convicted of nothing well
they they I can't believe that that many
Republicans voted
to throw him out I me 105 Republicans
voted to expel ridic many uh let's see
um more than 100 Republicans joined
Democrats to expel Santos and uh
Newsweek has the list Let's uh all right
let's grab a name it random we're going
to just going to shuffle it up a little
bit and then Ron estas of Kansas you are
a
scumbag unlucky guy unlucky uhoh did I
see Dan crenchaw on there oh God please
Dan kencha you're a scumbag why on Earth
would Dan crenchaw vote for that I don't
know man is there anybody in here I I'm
I'm I know that I'm going have to call a
scumbag because I will I will let me let
me go through see if I see uh uh we Dan
uh we almost had him on the show he's
been invited several times but he
canceled on us every time uh he's not a
scumbag for that he's allowed to cancel
on us you don't have to come on the show
nobody owes me any favors but voting to
expel Santos who is not convicted of any
crime is pathetic spineless Behavior
yeah so uh who's who's I I I don't know
if I know anybody in here cuz we like I
we're we're we mostly have the freedom
caucus people in here I mean you know
they they like to say oh Tim pool's
rightwing it's like it's like moderate
Libertarians on this show you know what
I mean so if it's like Freedom caucus
people we're usually friends with them
and they're usually doing the right
thing we don't got to worry about them
but uh as for the rest of these people I
don't even know who these guys are Ken
Buck sorry Ken you're a
scumbag Andy Bar
scumbag like you can you can apologize
after the fact all right but right now I
just call you scumbags anyway what were
we talking about uh how the Republicans
are unreliable and they will vote to
boot people that are Republicans whereas
the Democrats obviously wouldn't you
look at the way that the de like and
Grant this isn't in Congress but it's
still the same ideology the way the
Democrats are flipping out and and
making a massive issue over the firing
of uh president gay from Harvard right
they're all swearing up and down that
it's it's because of racism when woman
clearly had massive amounts of perjury
in her history and she made terribly
anti-semitic comments in front of
Congress that's totally justified to ask
her to step down especially considering
Harvard has a reputation to worry about
the anti-semitic comments alone are
enough for Harvard to be like you have
made remarks that do not line up with
Harvard's values you need to step down
that you can disagree but at least it
makes sense and to allow her to stay and
and sit there and and and run her and
and you know to to to not have take care
of the problem and and sit there and and
defend her as if she had done has done
nothing wrong and as if it's just based
on racism is absolutely insane but
that's the way that they behave there is
they will not go after their their own
and anytime there is a a in the
Republicans armor they're going to go
for it I can't wait you know cuz we got
uh we got elections coming up and we get
more and more elected officials running
for re-election who want to come on
shows like this well they're not going
to come on this show that's not going to
happen people say to me all the time
like Tim you got to be nice otherwise
they're not going to want to come on
your show and I'm like good I don't want
them I mean look you got coma on there
uh there there's absolutely people I'd
love to have conversations with but I'm
sorry man if you if if I'm going to be
I'm going to be a dick about it I think
I think one of the scummiest things you
could have done is how they could have
waited they could have been like okay we
got some evidence let's let's let's
let's get it documented as this country
is supposed to do to prove that he's
guilty and then get a unanimous vote and
be like you're guilty of this stuff you
get out of here man instead it's just
it's just guilty until proven innocent
at this point this is a it's a dark path
for this country and I'm sick and tired
of Republicans you know you know you
know I see and you know what so many
Americans see and and I think this is
why so many Americans are pro Trump and
voted for Trump in 2016 and I was late
to the party you you know it but it's
look at this Republicans get on their
knees for Democrats the Democrats crack
the whip on Republicans say you know
please may I have another
remarkable I will say this i' I'd love
to advocate for the impeachment of Joe
Biden at this point on principal grounds
but strategically please don't impeach
them man we need we let him stay in
there so he can lose in understand
impeach me you still got to convict in
the Senate so so in that case he would
not be removed but he would not be
removed from office and so we can do it
then you could impeach him but you
there's no way he'd be convicted so what
I say to people is look we got an
election coming up here in November so
you want to get rid of him that's that's
the best effective way to do it Missouri
state senator be Bill eagle sponsored a
bill to disqualified Joe Biden from the
2024 ballot Alex posted this Al Alex
posted this uh at 8:22 p.m. today uh it
says uh you know what I I think i' I'd
love to advocate for the impeachment and
conviction of Joe Biden but I think
you're right because we were for a long
time like this guy the barisma stuff I
mean the Border stuff I I think the
border the the the facilitation of the
of the immigration crisis he's suing
Texas now he's facilitating this I think
you can say this is high crimes and
misdemeanor all that stuff mhm but I
kind of think if the Republicans impeach
Joe Biden thinking hey we'll earn some
political points he'll never get
convicted he'll get convicted Democrats
will be like oh gee you know what
Republicans you're right Biden's got to
go good luck good luck in November
because then they bring in Gavin Newsome
and they they would love to get Joe
Biden to swap out somehow with gruesome
Newsome yeah gruesome Nome we couldn't
even impeach my orcus who's Homeland
Security secretary who won't enforce the
border and you know he'd be easier to
impeach him we still haven't done that I
so I I hate the fact that they are so in
unable to do anything like uh we're
going to talk you know we're going to
have V ramaswami in the uh okay uh next
week and you he's talking about making
major major Cuts real substantive Cuts
Like I would love to see the government
just shrink a little bit never mind you
know I mean well actually I would love
to see the government stop growing and
stop trying to in insert itself into you
know things that essentially are are
personal and stuff um but I mean I would
I would I would give you know just
anything to see it just stop growing you
know just stop first doing first stop
doing more harm yeah you know that's
what you do first thing you do is stop
the bleeding right let's let's pull up
this story we got this tweet from Alx
Missouri state senator Bill igel
sponsors a bill to disqualify Joe Biden
from the 2024 ballot all right what's
his argument he says in the wake of the
formal efforts and 30 3 states to remove
president Donald J Trump from the ballot
said Senator Bill igel will be putting
forth legislation that would disqualify
Biden from the ballot in Missouri saying
the following by the democrat's own
standard Joe Biden should be immediately
disqualified and removed from the ballot
for the aid and comfort he has given to
our enemies our country is being invaded
because Joe Biden has swung our Southern
border wide open President Biden has
allowed more than 8 million people to
stroll across the border illegally
causing more harm to this country than
any other president in American history
my legislation exposes the absolute
absurdity of Colorado and Main decisions
to remove president Donald J Trump from
the ballot if radical leftists continue
to push lies and fairy tales in attempt
to kick Trump off the ballot in their
states Republicans have no choice but to
Buck up and fight back use the facts to
remove Biden from the ballot before he
destroys this country even further
Democrats only believe in democracy when
it favors them let's expose their double
standard hypocrisy we must stand our
ground to protect the security of our
nation and the sovereignty of our people
bill igel is the only Missouri
governatori candidate to endorse
president Trump in his 2024 re-election
big bid paid for by igel for Missouri
Thomas Hughes Treasurer I agree but uh I
got to tell you there's a uh it's a
pretty wild scenario when red States
pull Biden off the ballot and blue
States pull Trump off the ballot because
then it what the election it's it seems
kind of silly but what's how how does
this play out when it comes to November
have an idea you remember Office of the
President elect when I just Googled this
they like rolled out this gas liting
campaign and now it has an official the
president elect of the United States is
the candidate who has presumptively won
the United States presidential election
and is a waiting inauguration to become
president they will just say he's the
falsely taken off the ballot president
of the United States and then they'll
have like well no what will happen is
Democrat corporate press sources will
say Biden one and like here here's
here's the thing if every single media
Outlet in this country declares a
presidential Victor that person's the
president end of story yeah because it's
just the it's the it's the it's a It's
The Confident popular narrative facto as
media
bifurcates if at the end of this year we
see CNN that gets what a couple hundred
thousand in their ratings and only
880,000 in the key demo when they come
out and they say Joe Biden wins and then
all the alternative outlets and podcasts
are like no Trump won then what happens
so what we need here's my advice to
every single uh Trump
supporter what you need to do right now
is start asking how you get access to
the tabulation data the same way CNN
does how does CNN get the numbers
reported to them get the numbers
reported to your your news Outlet Daily
Caller daily wire how about we watch The
Daily wire for their election
tabulations and not Fox News or CNN
because when it came to calling Arizona
everyone was complaining in 2020 because
why did Fox News call it so early we
we're still awaiting a lot of
information and a lot of data okay well
imagine if as all this information's
coming in you have the daily wire
crowter even Joe Rogan who knows all
these independent Outlets media Outlets
uh and they all say it does not look
conclusive we're still awaiting a
potential two or 3% we don't know who's
going to win this state then all the
corporate press calls it for Joe Biden
then a point goes in favor of trump so
everyone else calls it for Trump then
what then what uh
be it's gonna be real interesting Joe
Biden's GNA have 30 million votes Donald
Trump's gonna have 30 million votes
because they're only going to be on the
ballots in the states where the states
already support Trump or
Biden what's going to be really
interesting is if a swing state tries
taking Trump off now Maine is the first
step because Maine has uh Trump won one
electoral vote from Maine in 2020 right
so if they take him off the ballot they
did that's one electoral vote taken from
Donald Trump already could make it
difference yeah definitely I think uh
Thomas Massie tweeted this already so I
think a potential
scenario he said to these states that
are doing this you realize like we the
house is going to be the group that
determines whether or not we accept
these the these these the state
tabulations so I'm curious uh R
Mooney let me let me let me let me I'm G
be very very careful with this one so
I'm going to pull up what uh Massie
actually tweeted
okay so that we can uh let's see
uh GOP rep warns house has final say
over election after States deem Trump
ineligible for ballots so let's get rid
of this little video here Thomas Massie
issued a warning to States moving to
keep former president Trump off the
ballot saying Main Colorado and other
states that might try to
bureaucratically deny ballot access to
any Republican nominee should remember
the US House of Representatives is the
ultimate Arbiter of whether to certify
electors from those
States would you vote to certify a state
that arbitrarily removed Donald Trump
from the ballot no I don't see how you
could and that's a good warning that
Massie said now we Republicans would
have to maintain control cuz the
Democrats I think if they took over
Congress would certainly certify those
States and not rejected so y he's
presuming with our four- seat majority
you know so you mean how I would vote
you know but if we want to effectively
that's actually a very good warning
because we went through this of course
um last cycle as well where the states
do have to certify yes or no so if you
take a state who threw somebody off the
ballot the leading candidate for
president off the ballot without any
justification which would be the case I
don't see how you can vote to certify
that state and then uh neither candidate
reaches 270 electoral votes well I mean
his are thrown out uh so yeah well uh
then then Congress then there there's
other Provisions in the Constitution
where uh there there has to be there's a
way there's a way to certify them um
another determin there's a determination
that can be made to certify them so uh
so see that let's say that uh Colorado
won't get counted we now have we have
this story from sr.com Illinois voters
file petition to remove Trump from 2024
ballot so Illinois is a potential let's
say uh Illinois did it say voters voters
yeah well all all of these it's not so
in Maine it was actually a petition from
uh from voters and then the Secretary of
State said Okay I I agree and got rid of
it so let's say Illinois moves to remove
Trump and they do Illinois was going
blue nobody expected to go red but
that's 19 electoral votes that Joe Biden
loses so let me ask you this if Illinois
removes Donald Trump yeah but Illinois
come on it's a blue State it's not going
to go red would you still say you would
you wouldn't vote to certify I don't
think I would you know um I think I
wouldn't the but I'm not I'm not in
Congress yeah I think it gets kicked
back the state the Secretary of State's
the one who gives the gives the you know
the certificate the state state
legislator is supposed to oversee it
state legislators have generally
deferred that to the Secretary of State
and that was sort of the issue so I
think there's a role for the state
legislators here as well so you you know
depending on what state they're going
after if a state legislator legislature
wanted to come in and send a a a group
of electors uh if you say the federal
government rejects say we did reject the
states electors and I think the state
legislators of that state may have the
opportunity to send a uh send electors
in and it could be resolved that way
potentially this could be wild if uh if
nobody hits 270 it goes to a contingent
election yeah and then it's house
delegations that each get a vote and and
Trump would win yeah that's true goes to
the house and then what what does I mean
can you imagine what the cities of the
United States would look like if that's
how Trump won I got to be honest uh I
don't care what they'd look like you
know why I think they it's their own
fault they I don't live there yeah and
they're and they're they're Democrat
stronghold so if they tear themselves
apart over themselves like okay good
luck guys yeah I mean I'm I'm worried
about the the swing back there's already
a lot of a lot of things on the right
that I don't like to see you know
there's a lot of people talking about uh
you know Christian nationalism and
Christian Prince stuff like there's
there's some some there's this dude
Richard wolf that's that's written a
book about you know nationalism and
stuff and it's it's kind of ugly look I
don't want you I'm I'm an atheist or
well I'm an agnostic and I'm not really
interested in living by someone else's
religion and like my hope is that we
don't have to go far to the other side
and that's what happens when communist
or you know when the left gets too
powerful the Right comes in and they
start shoving boots in people's ass so
we end up with the United States
fracturing into two countries this would
mean that certain blue areas are
occupied and certain red areas are
occupied but the uh northernmost areas
would become the corporate states of the
unip party and the southern states would
become the abrahamic kingdom of America
I just have such a pro like I was it's
so hard to predict you know to to guess
what's going to happen anyways once you
put something like that big into play
like the the idea of the US not having a
a clear president or or you know cons
consistent civil unrest that's you know
beyond the stuff that you saw in 2020 I
mean there's a lot of AR there's a lot
of a lot I give a lot of credibility to
the argument that the International
Community might say look the United
States has more nuclear weapons than
anyone else if their government is you
know is not solid then we should have
the UN or whatever go and and help
support the United States federal
government end up with you know foreign
troops on us soil and and I again I'm
not saying that I'm predicting that but
it's like these things are well within
possibility you know so you guys are GNA
love this can't hear you what you can't
hear you bro I said oh sorry you guys
are gonna love this I don't know if Tim
wants to see this but what is it what
you're doing on the the map oh well I'm
what I'm just calculating what what's
going on here in these United States
based on the polling data that I've
received we're just going to go ahead
and make our uh our predictions as to
what's going to happen here
just been doing this in the background
just while you guys are talking I'm just
I'm going over the voting data over here
and it's looking pretty good bring that
bad boy up not going to have any
problems at all in the next election if
that turns out and uh it's it's looking
it's looking good uh Democrats with one
Republicans with 537 electoral votes so
that looks like a I guess I would call
that a a slight win for Donald Trump
2024 look at this this map proves it you
see this map it's a mud
slide prove
there you go it's uh it's coming ladies
and gentlemen states do change over time
California used to be very Republican
and you know why it's not
anymore because Ronald Reagan signed a
mass amnesty Bill legalizing
non-citizens who then engaged in chain
migration and in 1994 after proposition
187 was was was uh signed into was was
ratified orever cified that would take
away access to public goods for
non-citizens the family members of these
non-citizens who became uh so they their
children are now in Revolt over how
their non-citizen family members would
lose access to public services and the
protests resulted in a major swing
towards the Democrats which the uh
California has never recovered from so
you know a lot of people like to point
out well there there weren't so many
illegal immigrants when Ronald Reagan
enacted those reforms the fascinating
thing
is uh let's say you live in a big house
and it's you let's say you got 10,000
squ ft or let's just say 10 bedrooms and
you share with one person and then one
day that one person lets in his buddy
and you say hey man you can't let your
friend in here he can't live here he's
got to pay rent like oh come on man it's
fine if he lives here's he's not on the
lease he's not on the lease he's going
to get us in trouble and plus we paid
the security deposit already dude come
on he refuses to kick him out you guys
keep fighting about it you don't know
what to do the cops are like we're not
getting involved eventually he says I'll
cut a deal with you you let him live
here I'll do the dishes and you go fine
now what happens that dude invites his
buddy over and you go go dude no you
can't bring your friend in and they go
two against one we win and now they vote
nope we we every everybody who wants
John to stay here everyone raise their
hand now two guys vote against you one
guy and now there's three of them and
then they invite two more of their
friends and they say five against one
six against 1 7 12 13 14 and that's what
happens to California I was resear I was
reading on how California turned turned
from red to blue it was it was not
reliably a deep conservative state it
had a Democrat uh State Legislature it
was fairly Progressive but Republicans
were fairly dominant until they invited
a whole bunch of people in gave them
citizenship and those people had more
ties to external communities than
internal communities so when it came to
the question of should we give public
goods and services to people who are not
citizens there was a large percentage of
the population that was in favor because
they had a larger tie to a non-citizen
community than a Citizen Community and
it's fairly obvious why is Joe Biden
ripping open the southern border because
in 10 years the same thing will happen
you invite people in Grant them amnesty
they will vote against you and they will
vote to take your stuff I'm for
immigration it's got to be legal
immigration imigration there's got to be
you take a test you learn about America
you learn about our values our court
systems and then you adhere to and abide
by that and assimilate into American
culture and we welcome you you should
have to want to become an American I
don't understand that that's again this
is something that when when I was
younger that that was kind of a given
but now it's like you know come to the
United States and live in this space but
you don't have to become an American and
that's that that's something I I don't
understand you should want to assimilate
to the you know the the to the values of
the country that you're living in you
can still be whatever you know you can
still have whatever Traditions or
whatever that's one of the great things
about the United States is you're free
to live your life however you want but
you just have to allow other people to
live and you have to understand that the
United States government isn't here to
provide for you most immigrants are
people that come in and want to work
hard right you know but like there are
too many that come in and just stay
under the radar and then like chain
migration and stuff so so the it's not
even necessarily about chain migration
which is a which is a big issue and I
think we should make that illegal uh
people uh you can sponsor non-citizens
to come into this country it means you
are legally responsible for their
Financial State and their debts for a
certain amount of time so this is a
component of how chain migration happens
uh what we're seeing with Chinese birth
tourism a Chinese woman will fly to the
United States on like with a with like a
multi-month Visa give birth to a kid who
is now a Chinese National and American
citizen when that kid turns 18 he can
sponsor his family from China so that
they can come and live to the United
States legally and then the the child
assumes the legal responsibility we
should get rid of all that but the the
issue is actually really really simple
for people to understand what's going on
if your parents are from the United
States and their grand and your
grandparents par are from the United
States your cousins your brothers your
sisters are from the United States maybe
you you're from Chicago and your cousins
live in debuk and your grandparents are
from Westchester PA and they moved to uh
ill you know Illinois and and were young
and your dad's family is from
Utah when you are thinking of how you
can vote to protect your family your
future your values your traditions and
everything you believe in you are
worried mostly about the United
States but if you come to the United
States as someone seeking a
job we don't need to speculate as to
what you do they make money at their
jobs and send that money back to their
home country when it comes to do or die
the voting pattern will be to protect
their families the only issue is they're
not voting in the interest of Colorado
they're voting in the interest of
Honduras now I get it I got no disdain
for somebody who wants to support their
family and I've got no disdain for
somebody who wants to live in the United
States the issue is when you have
completely unfettered flooded Invasion
on the border 10,000 plus people per day
the system cannot sustain that and we
are going to end up with a massive
percentage of the population that will
absolutely vote to strip your assets and
send them to foreign countries and
that's probably why it's been happening
for a long time so I you know what I
think we need to do elect Donald Trump
largest deportation campaign we've seen
for all of the uh illegal immigrants and
non-citizens uh legal residents legal
immigrants have my utmost respect and I
I say we give them a hand we clap for
them you came here you did it right you
respected us we respect you and we want
you to have opportunity and my view is I
agree with v h-1bs you know Hannah Clair
and I were arguing this the other day
I'm a big fan of h-1bs but they have to
be legitimate meaning if I cannot hire
someone in the United States because the
talent does not exist then I say I want
to get a visa for this person who's from
the UK or from India or from wherever
and bring them to the United States the
us then begins stripping away the high
value assets and labor force from other
countries strengthening our economy our
industry at the same time we should be
restricting lower level immigration
severely because we've got way too many
young people who can't find jobs if we
allow all of these non-citizens these
illegal immigrants to come across the
border and then they say oh but but but
look they they they need work they need
jobs yeah well 16-year-old kid who needs
a summer job needs a job too you you say
low scale way wants someone to work in a
meat processing plant yeah I got a
16-year-old kid who can do that job and
wants to do that job and he's happy to
make 15 bucks an hour doing it Donald
Trump had a raid on several meat
processing plants in the South when he
was president it resulted in like 600
deportations all these Liberals are
arguing nobody would do these jobs they
had no choice but to bring in illegal
immigrants when journalists went down to
the hiring fairs these companies had
after I think the companies should have
been shut down by force by the
government for breaking the law but when
they go down there what do they find a
bunch of American citizens applying for
jobs and they went they asked this one
guy why are you applying for a job at
this plant nobody wants these jobs
because are you kidding pays 14 bucks an
hour that's two bucks more an hour than
I was getting my other job yeah
Americans will take these jobs the wages
will increase but when I look at this
stuff I'm so pissed off because Joe
Biden is in violation of the
Constitution and he is aiding and
abetting criminal activity you know what
let me show you the proof someone
tweeted this earlier it's from August
12th 2021 from the United States
Attorney's Office Southern District of
Texas young soldiers admit to
transporting undocumented citizens my
stars and GS you mean if you transport
non-citizens you are breaking the law I
got questions for the Biden
Administration but more importantly let
me say this as clearly as I can to each
and every one of you border patrol
officers and law enforcement officials
for the federal government who are
taking orders from your hups telling you
to transport non-citizens illegal
immigrants to all those crew of Swift
air private Airlines I will not forget
nor will anyone who's watched this show
nor will any politician we petition we
will never forget that under our laws
you are committing crimes and you think
simply because it's ubiquitous you will
get away with it I assure you you will
not if you wear a badge and you are
instructed to break the law and you
break the law we will not force for get
this is from justice.gov
2021 two military men Station at Fort
Hood have entered guilty pleas to
conspiring to transport undocumented
aliens within the United States
announced acting us Attorney Jennifer B
lowly now how is it that three years ago
two and a half years ago it is a
criminal offense to plead guilty to if
you're transporting undocumented aliens
in this country but now how many law
enforcement officials govern government
contractors and all you employees of
Swift a are doing just this without a
care in the world I hope I beg and I
pray that when Donald Trump is elected
he arrests each and every one of you
because you are breaking the law and
simply because you all did it with your
friends doesn't mean you get away with
it when I saw this I was
pissed I have no problem with any of the
quote unquote destruction that Donald
Trump is talking about and in fact I
don't think that Donald Trump will go
far enough if he actually does get
elected people forget even Obama when he
was president deported hundreds of
thousands if not millions of legal
immigrants Obama himself enforced that
law he was the deporter and chief the
phenomena we're seeing now with Joe
Biden with the poorest border and and
taking the dollars that taxpayers give
to the border security to use it to
bring them in this is actually a new
phenomenon even for Democrats even for
Obama and you can't you say I oppose
this so you hate you hate they attack
you you hate this you hate that but
Obama did it yeah cuz he used to
understand that if you have taxes you're
asking for like taxes from a tax base
you have to have a close system you
can't just open up to the world and then
give to everybody you can't there's no
way you're going to be able to fo that
bill it's ridiculous there was a CBP guy
who pulled up in his truck to the razor
wire in Texas and saw illegal immigrants
trying to enter and he said turn around
now he's under investigation they're
putting they're getting him in trouble
for it he's doing his job he's enforcing
the law that's a good man and the Biden
Administration expects you to break the
law but I just I just I'm going to read
this for you they say these men face up
to 10 years in prison and a possible
$250,000 maximum fine when I was in
Chicago over Christmas we had a shuttle
driver bringing us to our uh we are
connecting to what did we fly back on we
flew on
um American maybe I can't remember and
uh this shuttle bus driver said that he
they they also did uh they serviced
private planes they jet so they got
worded the Blackhawks were coming
Chicago Blackhawks oo big hockey fans
and the 737 pulls up full of passengers
they pull their car up open the the the
forward cargo uh on the belly of the
plane three garbage bags and they were
like what is this they load the garbage
bags onto their car and they were like
they shrug and then they found out the
plane was transporting illegal
immigrants into Chicago I asked him I
was like they he said they lied to us
they told us it was the Blackhawks and I
said did they lie to you because you
would not have served illegal immigrants
had you known that's what they asked you
to do and he goes yep so the only way to
get these crew members to actually to
facilitate these planes is to trick them
into doing it cuz that's a good guy he
was telling me I would not have done
that if they didn't trick me I say you
sir are a victim they tricked you but
all these guys they know what they're
doing and I'm I'm just I I I beg and I
pray man I want Donald Trump to get in I
don't think he'll do it because it's
it's important to point out Trump is not
a dictator he never was and won't be
Trump's going to go in there and he's
going to say look we love our men and
women in uniform we're not going to hold
it against them we're going to go for
the leadership I get so many
conservatives in here being like I'm not
going to blame the police for what they
did I'm going to blame the higher-ups
and I'm like oh no if it were me I'd go
to each and every every individual and I
would say sir you can put on the chains
on your ankles right now I'll put you in
the jumpsuit you committed this crime I
don't care if if a vision came to you in
your sleep of a prophet telling you to
commit the crime I don't care if your
mother told you to do it I don't care if
Joe Biden told you to do it you broke
the law you broke the law if Joe Biden
says go rob a bank you you rob the bank
but these people I'm I'm I'm worried
they'll get away with it and then this
is what happens we supposed to forget 10
years from now we'll just forget that
this happened I hope
not all right it's been a good show
everybody thanks I mean what do you do
when the President says to do something
like that I mean is that look I'll give
I'll give it the big ask I don't expect
Donald Trump to start locking up all of
our la law enforcement we need law
enforcement but these people should have
a reckoning of some sort I think they
should get their pensions stripped from
them or something like that what'll
really end up happening is I will say
something like Donald Trump must arrest
anyone who committed committed these
crimes and then Trump will say well
we're not going to do that too far but
we will do and then we'll get something
out of it the scary thing is what if
what if like I mean his entire first you
know first term the first for the whole
four years the FBI or at least half the
FBI was working actively working against
him subverting the president
like it's legitimate to fire all those
people and the idea that it's not
legitimate to fire the people that are
wor like we should charge those people
we should investigate look for the
people that were actually trying to
subvert the directives of the
commander-in-chief the fed you know the
director of the of the justice
department is you know the president's
the executive he's in charge of the
whole thing human smuggling that's
that's what the justice.gov website
calls it human smuggling there there's
been a uh I guess even among some of the
least likely to fight colleagues of mine
that are Republicans a push lately to
not fund anything unless we get border
enforcement and enforce our immigration
laws because it is you know that obvious
to the American people even some
Democrats have been breaking we've had a
few votes where on the spending bills we
said this is contingent upon enforcing
immigration laws which is clearly not
happening and some Democrats have
started vote with us on this so I I you
know I you know I hear what Tim saying
obviously very passionate American
people see that too but it isn't just
President Biden frankly the the voters
gave us a republican House of
Representatives which has the power of
the purse and we fund this with your tax
dollars we don't have to do that yeah
this is a story that we covered quite a
bit we showed this to Marion Williamson
October 20th 2021 more migrant children
being flown to New York but what happens
to them after they
arrive you know I hope
that when Donald Trump gets
elected his attorney general will order
an investigation who will find the
pilots of these planes and put them in
prison for 10 years and I hope the
pilots of these planes hear what I'm
saying right now and I hope you know
every opportunity I get to speak to
people who are seeking these
positions when they when I see them
whoever it may turn out to be I will be
saying to them when you are in the White
House I want to see the people who flew
these planes in shackles I want to see
them crying on television after a per
walk saying I'm so sorry I was
trafficking children into this country
illegally they think because they work
for a corporation they're shielded I
want all of those people to know I will
do everything in my power to Advocate
you spend your life Behind
Bars I'm so sick of the banality of evil
of people who work for these companies
who facilitate crimes and think think
because Joe Biden is President and
because the president is corrupt you
will get away with it you're not just
doing your job you're breaking the law
and we're going to enforce the law the
way the law was written I'm just sick of
it man it's it's plain as day right in
front of us we've covered these stories
so many times there was uh who was it
there was some some reps from out of
Tennessee the Biden Administration was
taking illegal immigrants from the
border putting them on planes and flying
them at 2 in the morning to
Tennessee well if if that's a crime that
two men were pleading guilty to to
moving transporting undocumented aliens
the bid Administration is ordering
people to do it that's too bad for you
guys you're the one I we got to lock
them up lock them all up there should be
massive massive investigations massive
amounts of Investigations I the you
could I truly believe that you can just
have the FBI investigate the federal
government and they'd be busy for a
decade they'd probably never get done
because as they investigate there's
going to be more FBI the Federal Bureau
of Investigation now means investigating
the federal bureaus right or we could
just get rid of them I mean look if you
want to get rid of you know cabinet
level bureaucracies everyone that
watches the show a lot knows how I feel
about that get them out of there fire
people
unemployment but we never cut the bity
of evil man it's these it's the people
who sell their souls to the devil to
people say well you know what I'm going
to do it anyway yeah can't we can't live
that way but not that the it's I mean
part of this does fall on and it doesn't
fall on to the the the viewers of the
show but part of it does fall on to the
people of America because people don't
know anything about the way that our
government works so they can't even know
what they should be voting for or what
you know what what makes sense for them
to be voting for and I mean I personally
feel like people look at voting like
praying it's like oh if I go over there
and I I vote for for this thing then you
know hopefully I'll get it but voting
never turns out that way we got a Super
Chat kako says I'm a major US airline
pilot and was Furious when I found out
we had illegals on our flights I hear
you but they don't tell us good sir I am
not speaking of you you I believe are a
good man if you're an airline pilot and
they tell you routine flight have a good
day and you are not party to what's
going on then I think the simple thing
is we look at the flight manifests I
think law enforcement ask what happened
tell us what happened you say I'm just
an airline I had no idea what's going on
and we say all right man thank you so
much for helping assist and figuring out
who is facilitating this stuff and
that's it end of story and then I'm
specifically referring to there are
private
Airlines so I don't uh uh the guy told
me in Chicago it was Swift air and a lot
of people have said it's Swift air I
don't know if that's true it it's you
know whatever but uh that's what the guy
said yeah there's no way a Private Pilot
doesn't know what he's doing when the
the plane is loaded up with nothing but
illegal immig imigrants all carrying
those little baggies or whatever yeah
you can be like guy I'm not flying This
Plane are you nuts that's
illegal I I you know I I just I just
pulled up here from justice.gov let me
just make sure it's very very clear to
each and every one of you because we got
at least one airline pilot here if you
transport undocumented aliens you can go
to prison for up to 10 years so if you
are sitting in that pilot seat and you
see them boarding your plane and they
don't have tickets with names on them
because that's all already been what's
reported oh boy if you think you're not
going to get in trouble for that I got a
bridge to sell you you're you're going
to have to get off and be like I'm not
flying a plane with people who who don't
have tickets this is illegal that's
pretty insane do they go through
security and all that stuff it's hard
not to get on the plane in the first
place they had the tickets had no name
given and they're all carrying these
packets and there are people now if
you're a gate agent I I'm sorry dude I
worked for American Eagle Airlines which
is American Airlines Regional I loaded
planes did not work gate gate people are
the their they take your tickets and
they scan them if someone walks up to
you with a ticket and there's no name on
it you should be like I'm sorry sir you
can't get on this plan I know you could
do that
right you can't James O'Keefe tries to
fly and he's got four s's on his ticket
and he gets pulled aside for a random
screening but these illegal immigrants
are being trafficked and they have
tickets with no names on them and the
gate agents are like what do I care I'm
getting paid baby well I hope you get
locked up too now and look I got look
I'm sorry I'm going to say this to the
pilot you find out after the fact you're
on a plane with with illegal immigrants
and you didn't know I can respect you
did not know I I'm I'm not trying to be
unreasonable the gate agents know for a
fact the gate agents have to let them
through yeah all of them should go to
jail well if you find out afterwards
that's like knowledge of a crime after
the fact right is do you you have to
report that to
somebody uh I don't know that you go to
jail because you may have witnessed a
crime you're unsure of and didn't report
it I mean that'd be that'd be crazy like
you see a guy leaving a bank with a
burlap bag or whatever and you're like
well it's none of my business and
they're like you should have reported
you're going to jail and no come on like
you don't you don't know what's going on
so I'm not going to blame in this
instance like a pilot who's sitting in
his chair ready to take off and he gets
like you have this x- money passengers
and he goes you got it and then later on
they're like there were illegal
immigrants there go like I had no idea I
can respect that gate agents all know
though illegal illegal immigrant walks
up with their packet and their and their
ticket obvious this is this is this is
crazy you and I both know that gate
agents are frequently uh entirely
disinterested in what's going on around
them I mean they're they're not they're
not particularly you know they're not
really paying attention they're kind of
just moving people through like they
they don't their jobs yeah even if they
did report it they reported to the
person they're reporting to was the
person saying to do it anyway I mean
they should report it but the person
they're going to they're going to ignore
it but at least they'll be on record
they report you think you could go to
TSA and be like hey you know TSA blah
blah blah in TSA apparently would be
like oh that's fine with us someone
someone chatted Tim fell off the fence
but I got to tell you guys if the sides
of the fence are we enforce our laws or
we don't yeah we got big we got big
problems is the the the fact that we
have laws that we do and do not enforce
that's a massive problem like if you
don't know what to expect from the
government that puts everybody a
position where they're constantly
anxious about what the government is
going to do and also that's part of how
it was possible for authoritarian
regimes yeah I was waiting for it to
come back with that yeah exactly to
start turning to start turning family
members in and that's again that's
that's what it was it wasn't just every
lies to each other because no one
actually knows what the truth is anymore
yep and then you're just kind of all
screwed and you hear people talk about a
low low trust Society versus a high
trust Society I mean it's a nightmare
living in a low trust society and our
society is is degrading because of
things like the government doesn't
equally you know uh enforce the law so
Ashley stclair posted this video
December
19th and she says my Delta flight from
Phoenix appears to be flying migrants
who cross the border and are being
shipped to New York when I asked a Delta
representative if this was the case his
response was what does it matter they're
humans too lock them
up it is it is it is insane to me that
the gate agents allow people onto the
plane with no name what if one of these
plan we just had a uh what was what was
it we actually have this tweet I think
from uh from Ashley stclair let's P this
story Ashley stclair tweeted hey United
on July 29th the United plane was nearly
total after a hard Landing who was
flying that aircraft was the co-pilot a
former flight attendant who was fired
and then rehired through United's
Diversity Program despite being on a
list to not return to United am I
correct this individual failed multiple
trainings including simulator training
am I also correct that the u United has
covered up this diversity disaster and
many others was the number two at the
Denver hiring center also onboarded
through Dei did she or did she not
change fail grades for Dei hires because
it makes the numbers look bad did the
instructor who failed this co-pilot ask
corporate why they passed him Elon Musk
responds if this is true this puts a lot
of lives at
risk it is true
my friends if there are employees of
Airlines who are allowing people onto
planes without giving their names you
thought 911 was bad we knew the names of
those guys now they're letting hundreds
if not thousands every day and they have
no idea who they are and so when I hear
something about a plane nearly being
total to hard Landing I get freaked out
am I going to board a plane where there
are people on it that did not pass
security and we don't know who they are
and then what happens if they hijack the
plane there's no security screen there's
no vetting of these
individuals I had to go I have TSA Prix
so I have to go for a meeting where I
give all my information bring my my ID
cards and then I get to keep my shoes on
when I go through security when I travel
my friends they had take their shoes off
these people don't even have to give
their
names that's insane but I think it goes
to show
you I I you know margorie Taylor green
has talked about National divor
you do not have a country if laws are
being broken and massed to the tune of
10,000 plus every day and it's not just
10,000 laws each of these individuals
who illegally cross the border are
breaking a multitude of laws each of the
employees of these Airlines these Bus
Charters and these uh uh private
Charters every one of those employees
are breaking the law
too at this point laws are basically not
being enforced at all in this country
only selectively against the political
opponent on of unip party establishment
figures I don't know how you have an
argument that the United States
exists well back to the immigration like
for people who don't want to enforce
immigration laws you got to ask the
question should we have any immigration
laws at all if we have any laws no
matter what they are any laws at all at
some point if it's broken will you
deport anybody and you know for those
who say it's heartless like the woman
said they're people too and stuff like
that the the the gate attendant who said
to the lady other people too does she
believe in enforcing any laws related
immigration or can anyone come here 500
billion Chinese can arrive tomorrow well
there are people too let them all in so
it's either you have a law and you
enforce it or you don't and enforcing
any laws always uncomfortable and just
to take the immigration away from a
second say a man commits a robbery gets
caught gets sentenced a 5 years of jail
that main man may have a 5-year-old
child at home who doesn't want his daddy
to go to jail but Daddy broke the law so
therefore you have to enforce it and yes
innocent people that the 5-year-old
child loses his father for 5 Years cuz
the father robbed a store that's enfor
so so it's not an easy or UNC uh
comfortable thing to do always to
enforce the law but either we have the
rule of law or we don't whether you like
it or not whether it's comfortable or
not whether you think it's Humane or not
it's it's it's do you believe in
actually enforcing laws any laws well
they don't they the left doesn't there's
a video going viral right now of a man
being arrested because he jumped Turnell
in uh the New York Metro and they're all
saying oh my God why are the police
doing this to this man and I'm like
because he broke the law and they're
like but why are they being so violent
because he's resisting arrest and
fighting with them they should let him
go that's they should enforce the law
yeah there's no law but they don't want
the law enforced no and if they get
their way these
leftists then you may as well not own
land you may as well not have a job
they're going to come into your house
they're going to take whatever they want
no one's going to enforce the law that's
the world they live in that I mean
that's the desire the idea you know
there are people on the left that think
that even owning property is somehow
oppressive
so the the idea that you own anything is
is offensive to them but when you're
talking about like the the way that they
they behave when it comes to enforcing
the law this is something that I harp on
again there's this guy in the 60s called
uh Herbert maruse that wrote up a paper
called the uh what was it the uh um Li
uh repressive tolerance and essentially
the argument he made in the paper was
that if you are on the left you should
forgive whatever people on the left are
doing up to an including violence and if
you are if you're on the left and you're
dealing with someone on the right then
they should be silenced they should be
uh you know they should be censored as
much as possible up to an including
thought if possible so you can't have a
a society where half the society
believes that the other half of the
society shouldn't have the ability to
express themselves to talk any of their
ideas must be shouted down and that's
this impulse we see constantly on the
left and it's something that that is a a
big problem because we've got a society
that doesn't even listen to you know we
we we constantly are are bickering and
we don't hear each other out and there's
been studies that people in the center
and on the right know and understand the
arguments from the people on the left
the people on the left straight up are
so obsessed with the ideology they just
think if you don't think like us you
must be evil that's why it's always
bigotry always some kind of some kind of
moral failing so other somebody
Frederick basat you know book legal
legal plunder where if you go and take
somebody's money from and Rob it from
their house you going into jail but if
you pass set of laws to create a tax
system and you take 70% of what they
earn it's legal all of a sudden right so
that's what it's called Legal plunder
and it seems like a whole another thing
is to just not enforce laws that people
may not like selectively speak based on
situations like someone not paying to go
into the Metro System jumping over the
metro line or you know other and they
have this debate in in cities whether
you enforce loitering um you know
smaller like throwing rocks through
Windows some cities Broken Window yeah
they just choose not to enforce those
whatsoever which obviously leads to
Greater and worse crimes yeah the idea
that you can allow some crimes to go un
unpunished or whatever just be like oh
well this is a crime but we're going to
ignore it you can't do that because that
degrades the law overall like you there
should probably be significantly fewer
laws in most major cities right like the
the essentially the government can do
whatever they want whenever they want
they've got enough laws where they can
just say okay well you you broke this
law so we started the interaction etc
etc that being said um it doesn't mean
that the government should have
interactions with you all the time you
know they the there should be there
should be a limit to the an amount that
the government is going to to be
involved with you and it certainly
shouldn't be deciding oh we're not going
to enforce this law for you but this guy
over here we're going to look at the guy
that Daniel penny guy that in uh the guy
that that ended up accidentally killing
a guy um you know he wasn't the only guy
that was trying to stop him you know and
there were there have been other people
that have done significantly worse
crimes you know that that aren't being
held on $200,000 Bond or whatever you
know and and I think that that's that's
the the the consistency and the
insecurity of the population is the goal
because then you're too afraid to break
the rules or even get close to breaking
the rules it's like by any means
necessary becomes the thing it's like
it's always been by any means necessary
and then just everything everything like
Falls kind of makes sense once you look
at it that and realize that's like the
underlying message behind it all you
yeah yeah got to have equal enforcement
of the law it's just a yeah it's like
how how little are we asking here you
know and you talk about they always call
conservatives names like racists and
stuff they're the one selectively
enforcing the law we're just saying
enforce the law the same regardless of
any ethnicity race everything just be
equal to everyone that's that's white
supremacy that's what they call that
that's why VI doesn't said he wouldn't
condemn it because he knows what they're
saying is color blindness is white
supremacy correct what the woke left
want is racial segregation so that's
what they've actually been implementing
across the country and then they use
these code words to trick you and to
make you bend the knee I think go I find
that at least is as far as people
running for office there's a great fear
of being called a name like a racist or
a hater of any particular person or
group of people and the fear of being
called a name uh is is no excuse not to
do the right thing like secure the
Border you know you know enforce
immigration laws doesn't mean you don't
love everyone sure you can love everyone
I just think we should actually enforce
the laws of our country or we have no
laws in this country and those who want
lawlessness and selective enforcement
are the ones who are actually picking
and choosing government picking and
choosing winners and losers based on on
ethnicity and things like that just like
they want to pick the winners and losers
based on the energy you know coal let's
go after coal and it's got to be all
solar P you know government picking win
winners and losers and abusing their
powers all over the place so Ashley
stclair is who tweeted I'm in possession
of legitimate major airline boarding
passes for migrants that quite literally
have the name printed as quote no name
given incredibly difficult to post these
without putting the Insiders at risk
working on it this will continue to
unfold over the coming weeks but I can
confirm these are legitimate boarding
passes I'm at a loss for words for what
I am verify thank you to everybody
reaching out so if you if you guys
choose not to believe it you don't think
Ashley St Clair is on the level I think
she is on the level I know her
personally and I think she's very honest
and I don't think she would lie about
this that being said I look forward to
the release of these images you should
be able to in some way release them but
it is true because whoever printed them
out the companies will know who printed
them out it is also true that I will say
to Ashley and to those insiders you must
be brave and you need to stop working
for a company that is breaking the law
and blow the whistle before you are the
one who ends up in
prison know we need more everyday
American heroes like that in this
country we had a woman in Hardy County
West Virginia who the EPA declared a
trickle of water was a river and was
requiring her a farm to go over all
sorts of EPA regulations this is when I
first elected and she sued with the
support of the American Farm was sued
all the way to Supreme Court and won won
the case they offered her settlements
along the way but she said I'm not going
to settle because this isn't just for me
and my farm it's for all farmers and
everyday American Heroes uh can do this
and need to stand up uh and I would
applaud anybody that would under a
variety of circumstances you know
whistleblowers who undercover corruption
and show what's actually happening
because there's a lot of misinformation
a lot of hiding what's happening the
left wants to do things and not let you
know do it in secret now the're saying
in politics sunlight is the best
disinfectant and I love that saying
saying and you know we have of course
control in the house now and I do
applaud my good friends Jim Jordan and
James comr who run those committees for
bringing out whistleblowers who are
talking about corruption and covered up
evidence from the left and the unfair
application of the law this is important
for our country uh that that they
whistleblow that and I think you know
showing that makes a difference and you
can lead to the investigations we do
have subpoena power now on the house and
you know what they've arrested
Republicans for now you know Hunter
Biden won't come testify so you you have
double equal unequal application of the
law there as far as committee hearings
so uh we really have to expose this
stuff and I think that's one of the
things this show is about and I
appreciate that well so uh let's just
jump in a little bit before we go to
super chats what what are your plans
what do you got coming uh coming up you
got some bills in front of you oh I just
brought stuff in case you wanted to ask
you know we we uh you talk about the
wokeism stuff well let's go back to
immigration right now Mexico receives
$60 million a year in Economic
Development funds just for you know
build some uh build some buildings from
American taxpayers meanwhile there's a
porous border fentanyl's coming across
that border the president of Mexico
who's an out andout socialist and does
not hates America has said oh we don't
even we don't even do that here that's
an American problem you guys get
yourselves under control insulted our
country yet we give them $60 million a
year of taxpayer dollars so I have a
bill house resolution 3190 introduced by
me Congressman Alex Mooney that says you
get no Economic Development funds Mexico
until you certify you're not sent Fenton
all across the country across that's
just you know one thing not going to
solve the whole immigration crisis but
think of the stupidity and the craziness
of giving a country free tax dollars
that's harming Us in that way here's a
quick question where does that number
come from house resolution 3190 like how
does how does a resolution get a number
uh it's in order of when you put it in
so so you know the house res start at
number one every year yeah starts at one
every year yeah oh wow house resolution
one 2 3 four five actually I had a house
resolution five does everybody race to
get number one well the leadership
controls that so the Speaker of the
House the speaker of the house is going
to
decide yeah 1 through 10 I think is
pretty much it's always like the speaker
of the house is cool whatever you know
well you it's based on an issue that's
important American people like what we
campaigned on house resolution five is
called the parents Bill of Rights act
all it says is what they're teaching
your kids in school parents have a right
to
know doesn't reform the whole system it
just says some school systems believe it
or not in this country when it not let
the parents know what they're being
taught in the schools mcy County
Maryland was trying to do that and if
the guy ran for governor of Virginia
McCulla said parents should have no say
in what's going on in their in their
schools so that just says right to know
you think it'd be an easy one we did
pass that one in the house by the way
the Senate hasn't passed it so as far as
the numbers go yeah they're just once
you get past the first 10 or so it's
just when you put it in it gets randomly
assigned thousands of bills are put in
every year but I mean we have to go
through all these but I know we haven't
talked about digital currencies the
White House is actually working on a
federal digital currency program like a
national Biden run digital currency
program which we've never authorized
that's something Congress has to
authorize they are so paranoid about
Bitcoin cryptocurrency all that because
they can't control it they can't control
the American people if they have their
own monetary monetary currencies it
totally freaks them out I mean I've not
seen the Democrats in the left as
freaked out since about anything since
cryptocurrency came along so anyway my
bill bans that because Joe Biden
shouldn't even have a pilot program
we've not authorized a pilot program we
don't want American we don't want your
federal government controlling the
currency and cryptocurrency and tracking
all your purchases gun purch is you know
hick in China they have good good uh
good boy bad boy credits you know for
what kind of a citizen you are based on
what the government tracks in your
purchases so I just brought to some of
this stuff in case it came up what about
banning uh the Implement implementation
of social credit score systems yeah well
we we don't we haven't gotten there yet
but that's kind of where they're going
they even have one of my bills is a
merchant category code that separate
separately identifies firearm merchants
or ammunition Merchant for other
purposes so you swipe your card when you
buy some ammo you want somebody keeping
track of that that's that's the type of
stuff Biden is trying to push right now
through Department of Treasury so we
need to stop that so we don't even get
to the you know the ban on you know
passing a ban on the good citizen
credits we just don't allow them to even
keep track of that information I mean
people are being freaked out by the by
the information uh investment companies
are being asked to tell how much of your
investment goes to coal and oil and gas
just give me the information yes that's
all well that why are they asking for
that information I mean there's a reason
they're asking for that information they
want to do something with it it
eventually and that's you get to the
credits or the oppression yeah and it we
have to stop that stuff and it tracks
before it even gets gets further and
that's something I'm you know I need my
colleagues to to be supportive of do you
feel like people are aware of that and
and like someone like obviously like
Elizabeth Warren she's for total control
the of the you know financial markets
and stuff like that I understand that
but do you feel like you have um do you
feel like you have support from other
other people aside from the freedom
do you feel cuz I don't feel like the
Republicans are on the same on are all
on the same team and I don't think that
there are Republicans that actually
maybe they maybe if they do understand
things like cryptocurrency and stuff
like that I don't think that they see
the danger I think that they're I mean I
a lot of it I feel like you're dealing
with Boomers that have no idea and it
doesn't make any sense to because I'm
fairly technically Savvy and it took me
a minute to understand exactly the
ramifications of something like like the
the Bitcoin Network and and the
possibilities and stuff how do you feel
about the response you get from other
people when you talk about things like
social credit system that means that you
couldn't leave your house and stuff that
unites Republicans I'd say I mean even
some Democrats may be with us on that
but say for the four years I was on the
financial services committee I'm on it
now Jeb henling was chairman when it
came to the Democrats crying screaming
to regulate cryptocurrencies and they
were every hearing they yelling about it
we did absolutely nothing no bills
nothing we didn't have a hearings on it
we just let the free market go and let
let if that's what people want to do let
them do it and it and it actually
thrived for a period of time yeah the
first time they got to regulate the
cryptocurrency market was on the first
Co bailout Bill one these stupid
ridiculous big Omnibus two two trillion
and then there they slipped in the first
ever regulation of cryptocurrency and
now they're coming after people and
they're trying to and all they're going
to end up doing is sending it overseas
yeah they just going to do it in some
other country you can't that's not
something you can lock down it's the way
that cryptocurrency works you can't it
just doesn't have the they don't have
the ability the desire for
and that's what this is all about do you
have a right to make your own decision
or does government make that decision
for you even if it's a bad decision what
you eat you know what you eat what you
you know whether you have a donut you
what what you buy where you go you might
make what kind of healthc care you may
or may not want whether you even want
healthare you have do you have the
freedom to choose to not have healthare
or does government make you have
healthare and there's the view among the
left which is mostly the Democrat Party
these days they can decide for you
they'll make the decision for you and
that's that's true and this is why
cryptocurrency freaks them out they lose
total control people can buy and trade
on their own and the government doesn't
even know what's going on do you have
any this is a different subject um do
you have an opinion on or do you have an
idea are you even aware of it but the I
am have concerns about um compan like
the big tech companies obviously they
they track your data and I don't think
that they can do anything about it
because everything that happens in a
computer there's a law it just
automatically happens right like maybe
they don't need to track the keystrokes
on on your particular device but
everything that happens in in a computer
there's a log like that's what happens I
get it but that means that all of that
information is saved and it's also
subpoena and so James Lindsay again has
has talked about your data should be
your own and it shouldn't be something
that the the Big Data companies are just
scraping all the data they can and then
profiting off of it I think that I don't
know how you would do it but I I have a
problem with the federal government
basically having everything you do at at
their at their fingertips all they need
to do is go and and talk to the company
to get it because because it to me it
seems like it's they're just another
branch of the military industrial
complex or or an arm of the CIA but
logged in you know in everyone's home I
think it's pretty scary that they
collect all that data it really is and
we shouldn't allow it the debate we had
in committee specifically is say you
join I know any kind of company uh email
system and or your purchase you go to
any uh department store and you start
purchasing stuff the debate is whether
they have to ask you to opt in to
collect your data or you have to ask to
opt out and I would say my strong view
is you have to choose to opt in it is a
free country if you want to be able to
collect your data tell them yeah here I
want you to go and collect my data give
it to other people that sell stuff and
send me emails and give me phone calls
you opt in but they take it for them to
take it and you then have to go find a
way to opt out right it's like like
having an email bunch of email things
you keep getting you can't even find how
to unsubscribe you never subscribe in
the first place I feel like all I'm ever
doing is UN I just have like 30,000
emails just collecting in I just did
five unsubscribed yesterday to see if I
can clear it out but that's the debate
and and many Republicans unfortunately I
disagree strongly feel that you should
have to be required to opt out that
private companies should be able to
collect it unless you tell them
otherwise and so uh that that is the
debate we have and you know I think we
need to win that debate the other debate
is even when the internet was created in
the 1990 when it was brand spanking new
and you say we're at the same age I'm
not sure I think I'm a little older than
you I did not have a cell phone in
college I have three I have three
children and and it's hard for people to
understand that I didn't actually have a
cell phone until I was like in my late
20s how was life I didn't have that I
didn't I you know didn't have any of
that stuff we're bringing beepers back
yeah because no one here at timcast
answers their phones good uh and so it's
just like okay I'm gonna have to get
beepers for everybody that beat and only
I will have the number nice and if it
beeps it's me what if those were playing
all along we were just trying to get
beepers back bring beepers back yo
beepers were great weren't they remember
remember back in the Beeper days yeah
like a blue like the transparent blue
ones the really cool ones so crazy what
was that was that was that on the Iden
Network like doctors I thought it was a
doctor only thing but you know what I
like to say ially say when Al Gore
invented the internet in 1990s uh we had
actually identified you know the
Facebook's all the internet providers
from lawsuits if they censored your had
uh said something about you on the
internet was completely untrue which
frankly happened to me um and there's no
responsibility at all whatsoever whereas
if you say that to the newspapers like
you remember the Kobe Covington kid who
didn't went to the pro-life March the
Wasington Catholic
kidt like though yeah yeah I'm I'm a fan
um Covington Catholic that's funny cing
Catholic kid who went to the pro lifee
March and then was basically harassed by
a by a protester and the Washington Post
uh uh falsely state that it's stated
that he had harassed a gentleman y the
video came out proved def definitively
that this young man that did absolutely
wrong was was really the victim of that
whole thing he got a big settlement on
the Washington Post I don't know the
number but he would Washington Post had
to pay him millions of dollars because
he sued successfully for being smeared
and lied about you cannot do that to
Facebook or the internet you can't do it
they've been indemnified by law and I
don't usually find myself on the same
side of trial ORS here or anything like
that but I think it's a high time we
take away that that indemnification from
social media companies to just totally
lie about you or censor you yeah I I
think it's I think the way the standard
should be they do not editorialize their
rules and then they're identified but if
they editorialize their rules yeah you
get no protection so uh Facebook YouTube
all the like let's use YouTube as an
example because this was it was true for
Twitter but now that El's taken over
it's not as true uh section 230 was
supposed to be like we get it yeah
section 230 you're going to get a bunch
of weird crap and you can you can get
rid of that stuff right abuse pictures
crime all that stuff
you will not lose your liability
protection for reasonably moderating
objectionable material right they then
went really I think hate speech is
objectionable and they interpreted it
that way the law needs to be
clarified you cannot set editorial rules
like Twitter had a rule that if you
misgender someone you get banned it's
like absolutely you are now disqualified
from identif identification if you
choose to prop up certain accounts so
this was really interesting during the
there were hearings in in Congress over
um with Jack dorsy and I forget which
rep it was they pointed out that if you
live in this area in the DC Metro and
you log into Twitter as a you sign up as
a new user Twitter by default suggests
you follow Democrats oh jeez yeah I mean
and that's a huge problem yeah so if
they do that it's totally fine you do
but you are liable for everything set on
your platform all right we're going to
go to Super Chat so if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to Channel share the
show with your friends and head over to
timcast.net so we're going to we're
going to make it a podcast kind of town
hall sold out instantly 50 tickets very
intimate people are going to be hanging
out it's going to be awesome and uh
we're doing that on the 10th we we're
not going to make money from doing this
like let me just I want to make sure
it's very transparent timcast makes
money we sell memberships
timcast.net we do make money from that
us choosing to go to Iowa will cost us
$100,000 we will lose that money what is
the benefit I think it's good for the
overall uh company and the goal is
simply this one we want to do it we want
to be there on the ground in Iowa during
these caucuses we want to meet the
various supporters of these campaigns
and do a town hall with v ramas Swami we
want to counter the debates on CNN and
you know create a space for truth
tellers I think V is one of those guys
and that means it's going to it's going
to cost money to do the reality is from
a business perspective if we keep doing
things like that we create more
incentive for people to become members
so to put it simply what do you buy when
you buy a timcast membership you get
uncensored membersonly shows you get our
documentaries we got a couple we're
making more you get our other shows that
are fun and silly you get access to the
members only Discord to hang out and
that money goes towards investing in
culture covering the caucuses and making
this show better and better as as as as
as much as we can with your assistance
so consider it let's read your super
chats wrath with the first Super Chat he
says first congratulations sir you've
won the night nice Patrick C says I hope
Trump doesn't show any Mercy at this
point when he gets back in I'm done with
these people I can't stand it here here
Patrick I'm sure you've heard you heard
my rant earlier in the show very
passionate I think is what uh the
representative here called it passionate
passionate yeah I'm just pissed you just
call
whatever Raymond G Stanley Jr says Biden
says he doesn't Foster fear while also
saying that Trump and Maga are holding a
knife to the throat of their democracy
remember remember the 5ifth of November
for that will be the day of their
Reckoning isn't it amazing it's going to
be November 5th 5th coming up I mean
that's uh it's a British thing but uh
we'll take it too everybody's going to
show up with Trump masks on they're
going to cheer and celebrate Trump's uh
Victory all right kicks of kicks is that
how you say it Tim is your kiky Jey deck
just
RDW or is something else entirely please
would you go over a couple of your
favorite interactions the deck uses
unfortunately I will say yo it's been so
long since I've played Commander it's
been like a year I think the last time
Ian and I played was maybe like eight or
nine months ago um so I can barely
remember what's in my Kiki JY deck yeah
I don't know I'll have to go and check
it out I can tell you though my Kiki gy
deck I'm going to brag here anybody who
doesn't understand about what what I'm
about to say good the Kiki gy deck is
gilded the the sleeves for the cards are
gold every card that exists in a foil
iteration is foil and every other card
that exists is an original print so uh
I've got like Alpha and beta cards in
there it is the deck itself could be
made it's an expensive deck but I think
my version of it probably cost like
$10,000
it is like my prized Magic the Gathering
deck I've been playing Magic since I was
a kid I'm very proud that I was able to
build this deck and I made sure it was
the best it could possibly be that is
the one luxury thing that I've ever
bought like everything else is kind of
just like more practical or an
investment this one was like I really
wanted a premium Magic the Gathering
deck and I will be proud of that
purchase all right we'll uh we'll carry
on I also have a bunch of other
decks let's see what do we got
neglectful sausage says Bill Clinton
likes him young who doesn't we don't
need old bruised fruit
Jesus wow we like the ones that just
turned ripe and juicy ladies take note
yes but when Epstein says young there's
a different implication as to what Young
means look nobody wants to eat uh uh
nobody nobody wants to eat unripe fruit
you get it oh
dude I
mean man dude I don't want to get too
like n you know what I'm not even no
what are you going to say just like
thing is
like young girls are not as much fun as
girls that are like late 20s well so I
like it when sex looks like
Jiu-Jitsu you're going at it like with
someone not like your like the whole
like teaching thing or young
girls that's that's for I mean I
understand the look thing but like the
scientific data shows that the the
average age of male uh uh uh preference
is 22 and the scary thing is I find this
to be gross it would be younger but men
don't like imature women no so it ends
up skewing towards between like 22 and
and 26 that's why some people say 24 but
what they found was that men when they
send messages on on dating apps 22 gets
22y old one get more messages than
anybody else yeah and when they look at
like a guy's profile they see that 22
has at the individual level but the
creepy thing was there was studies done
where they showed images of teenage
girls and up to like older women two men
and asked them to rate them on their
beauty and sexual attractiveness the men
did not know the ages or anything about
the women and the 14-year-old girls
scored the highest good grief and people
need don't understand this because this
is why modeling agencies use 14-year-old
girls for heroin Chic it's it's
disgusting in my opinion when people I I
knew this because I known about the
modeling industry cuz I have friends and
family who are assigned to major labels
or major major
agencies and they'd be like you know
when you walk through the mall and you
see like the Victoria Secret thing I
shouldn't call it Victoria Secret I
don't know what their policy is they
they they may use you know of age women
but like you go to the mall and you'll
see like a lingerie or like a racy photo
those girls are like 15 16 years old
that shouldn't even be allowed it
shouldn't be allowed modeling agency
should not be able to do racy uh
modeling for of young girls 18 but they
yeah it should be 18 but they do though
and a lot of people don't don't know
this I didn't know that yep some of the
like most like most well-known or most
used models they're they're like 15 16
now don't get me wrong there are a lot
of models who are prominent who are in
their 20s to I'm not saying they're not
but I think people need to realize that
they if if if you're walking through the
mall and you see an advertisement and
it's this you know they'll I'll give you
an example it'll be like a woman she'll
be she'll be topless but her arms will
be covering her nipples and she'll be
making like a sucked face and it'll be
like a perfume yeah she's like 16 oh my
God yep messed up huh yeah it's
true all right we'll read some more
we'll read some more thank God Ethan
Helms Says Megan Kelly said don't be
surprised if we eventually hear from
Epstein himself y'all see that what did
she say that how was that when was
that she got a Ouija Bo she really she
thinks he's alive a recording there's a
recording out somewhere maybe something
like that yeah but there are a lot of
people who think he's still alive gotcha
yeah I don't know about whatever how
else they get him out the Ouija board's
still
funny the trooper says hey Tim can you
adjust your shirt again and say I get no
respect at all I tell you I I don't
understand what danger field I I don't
get I get no respect at all I tell you I
know what that mean of course I get
Rodney Dangerfield God I love Rodi it's
fascinating he got famous when he was
like
50 yeah he was he was doing comedy
didn't work and then finally he got on
himself and started making fun of
himself and everyone loved it and he was
like self-deprecating humor was amazing
the it's victimless yeah exactly you
know he doesn't make fun of anybody but
himself Y and it made him rich and
famous that's funny it worked yeah you
ever you guys ever see um what was that
movie called was called like back to
school or something yeah diving board
thing oh that that was so great uh I
have not seen that movie since I was a
real little kid but the most memorable
moment of the movie for me is when he's
arguing with the professor cuz the
professor doesn't actually know how to
run a business cuz he's he's in
University and then all the students
take notes from him because he's this
industry leader yeah good movie imagine
that Max reck says Tim you got to get
Destiny back on would be a great
conversation about Biden's corruption j6
Etc he certainly feels differently than
you do uh I like Destiny he's a good
dude like's he's been on the show
several times he's been on various forms
of it and we like we we we play poker
with him after the fact Destiny is a
sincere guy he believes what he believes
and he's not he's he's not it's no grift
no grift he I disagree with him but I
think he's a good dude uh so we we we
enjoy having him on to hear those
perspectives and the reality is like I
think for the bulk of things we we agree
with him and then when it comes to stuff
like this we disagree but I have
tremendous respect for him because we
were arguing about something like the
first time he came on the show and I
said something the effect of all they're
doing is lying exploiting a crisis to
implement their policy changes and he
said something likew when else would you
do it and I and then I kind of had this
realization like oh he's being honest
that he wants this stuff done I can
respect that if you tell me you think
policy should be changed in ways that
that bypasses the vote of the people or
like you don't think we should I I I I
want to be careful I want to drag the
guy or get his position wrong but if
your view is we should Implement radical
change during a crisis because it's it's
it's better and there are smart people
who know how to do it as long as you're
not lying to me because this is what
they do like you I think you mentioned
this before the show I don't know if it
was during the show you said everything
the Democrats Tred to do is the opposite
has the opposite effect has the opposite
effect yeah that's what I can't stand if
they came to me and said you look we
really hate homeless people so we're
going to implement these policies that
actually hurt them I'd say well okay I I
I disagree with you right but when you
come to me and say no no we're going to
help them we're helping yes and then you
burn everything down I'm like you're
lying yeah so but I think the saying
that we say in Congress what the left
does never let a crisis go to waste
every time something happens somebody
uses a gun inappropriately let's go ban
certain guns y you know oh let's go take
your freedoms away let's just shut down
things and you know are are you a big
gun guy or you like yeah of course yeah
no definitely so I was I was hanging at
a gun store I went to Alaska and uh
basically every store in Alaska when
you're not in the big city is a gun
store too because yeah if you're in the
middle of nowhere and you're going to a
general goods store they've got guns and
bullets or or something you know maybe
I'm not speaking maybe Alaska's no
better all I know is I went to a store
that sold chocolate bars and they also
had guns it made sense though because it
was a town of only a few 100 people and
So you you're living out here you need
your weapons but anyway we're hanging
out and then uh I was just part of
passively talking about this because the
guys who are with us one guy was from
Montana and I had to explain to them
that in Maryland M1 the M1A is is an
assault weapon it has been banned
explicitly and specifically as an
assault weapon but the scar 20s is legal
now for those that don't know anything
about guns yeah an M1A it's like okay
there's different variants or whatever I
suppose but semi it's it's it's uh well
semi semi-auto but it's like a Woodstock
uh uh the way it looks 308 or or 55 uh
no no s uh 7 uh
62 the scar 20s is a modern like AR-15
style 308 MH this the really simple way
to break this down is scar 20s modern
better better handling better weight
everything about it is better better
accessories more adaptable more mod
modifiable totally legal and fine
M1A which is reminiscent of like what
they used in Vietnam or whatever banned
as an assault weapon there is absolutely
no logic whatsoever behind this yeah it
was weapon of War scary ban it yeah but
what about a scar 20s they go I don't
know what that is and then we all just
like don't tell them they want to ban
the ones with scary names or that look
scary there's no logic to it you know 10
rounds of ammunition 12 15 I I love the
ksg2 totally fine and legal in in
Maryland you you know what that is do
you guys know what that is I know it is
a double mag tube 25 shell pump action
shotgun what and it's awesome and so
when we went to the range with it it's
we we we've got 2 25 rounds of Buckshot
it's just boom boom boom boom it
vaporized the wood the wood structure of
the target totally fine that and it
should be fine yeah but an M1A no not
low I'm looking at them both I don't
know if you have ever played Call of
Duty but it's like the the weapon you
start out with is an M1 and it sucks and
then you have to build your way up to
the Browning which is like the one that
you get out of the mystery box it's got
the things that come down it's fully
what is the G thumb because people from
the little clip snap thumbs smash the
Garand is actually really good there
it's it's a solid rifle it's just that
uh they wanted to update it because uh
they wanted to shrink the caliber or the
size of the bullet okay John Curry says
M1A is a beautiful rifle much nicer than
a scar I agree I do cuz Luke's got the
scar 20s and I've got an M1A and we go
to the range and I'm just like I like
mine better I do you know it is what it
is my favorite is my uh Winchester
repeater 357 Magnum it it's great I love
it a shotgun with 25 rounds would be
great for home protection that that that
crook running around your house you got
to reload man shot you're going to
get him but I'll tell I'll tell you what
I'll tell you what so it's got uh dual
mag Tube 12 shells each if you're using
if you use the sh so I forgot what
they're called but they have the shorter
shells the smaller ones you can get way
more in there uh but then you hold one
in in the in the chamber itself so it
goes 25 okay got it but it can switch
between the two mag tubes with with a
switch in the back so uh the great thing
about it is you can put your non your
less lethals or your bird shot in one
side and your lethals your Buckshot or
whatever else slugs in the other side
and so in the instance of Home Defense
it actually is is really great for home
defense you don't you don't necessarily
need the kg25 the kg uh uh uh uh itself
I think holds like 12 or whatever but
you can actually flick the switch and
use birdshot and then if things are
really dangerous you can flip the switch
and then use whatever else you've loaded
in the weapon yeah uh I always recommend
however everybody a few things is always
get training course guns guns are as
serious as they as anything could get
always follow the rules and they
actually have I don't know if you call
it gun insurance I think it's gun
insance I they call uscca has a has an
insurance policy that's available um but
that's where like if you get into any
legal issues they will they and it's not
expensive one of the things that the
left loves to do is they love to go
ahead and be like oh we should charge
everyone blah blah blah insurance I have
insurance and I pay like a hundred bucks
a year for it it doesn't cost anything
because nobody kills people with guns
that like you don't get insurance if
you're going to go and murder someone
like you
don't stupid idiots but you but any
anybody anybody into guns will tell you
get training first and foremost and the
funny thing is these leftists are like
we need to mandate this mandate that and
I'm like bro every single person at the
gun store will ask you to come to their
training course yeah of course and and
and will Advocate that you get your
training and learn the rules and all
that stuff before anything else and they
it yeah oh yeah for sure and not only
that like Luke Kowski for instance loves
doing it and loves bringing his friends
to do the training I have like 15
certificates I go to one I try to go to
one every every year I missed this past
year but I try to go to whether it be
rifle or handgun or something like that
I mean if you're going to carry a gun
which I carry a gun like if you're going
to carry it you need to go and get
training and like so yeah get training
all right ghost wolf Primal says Tim
have you ever talked to Nick fedus yes
he's been on the show I think twice he's
been on twice yes yeah he's a good dude
we like him he's great he says a
republican member of the House of
delegates in 2016 he is he's a good dude
like having him on all right let's uh uh
oh uh oh Jake the crypto snck says Phil
why did you have to ruin my night I'm
going to have to redo my whole pedal
board now oh man just get the regular W
pedal he just figured it out he didn't
know all along that it had that on there
most people don't know I mean that's why
that's why it got on there look if you
put like Hitler's 14 words everyone
would be freaking out obviously
correctly but like this slide this goes
under the radar because our entire
educational system is totally Red washed
McCarthy didn't go far enough agree here
here not like wed by one guy and made
signature it's just a w pedal it's just
a w pedal it's red it's got a star on it
it's got genocidal slogan on the side
there's many more that do not have
genocidal slogans on the side that I
would advise that person really had
history to figure that out I got to be
honest I mean do do do you really need
I'm going to get so much hate for this
but do you really need a pedal board at
this point I mean it depends if you're
going to do stuff live you can do it
without it but like I just have a a
multi-pedal like mixer board you know
what I mean like you get two of them
you've got eight pedals yeah I that's
fine I think like getting like a whole
bunch of crazy pedals and having this
like array of $500 pedals is it's fun
but you know do you need to I don't know
look all you really need is just the
expression pedal and then honestly you
can just program it into your show so
that way all the changes happen on your
on your Axe effect at the right time and
they're all triggered by your click
track so you don't have to worry about
changing pedals or dancing around it's
all programmed it all runs off the click
right I almost put a chaos pad on my
guitar yeah wow yeah I think I think
Matt Bellamy of muse had that like in in
the actual body of it I think he had a
custom build with a cast pad in it I'm
not sure not 100% sure but I took a mini
chaos pad for those that I don't know
what that is it's like basically a
touchpad that when you touch it it makes
sounds and you can move your finger
around and and it it has different axes
as to what the sounds will do XY X yeah
so like tone and like modulation or
whatever and uh that he put the guitar
through the chaos pad right yeah so when
you strum you could hit the chaos pad
and I I think Matt had the chaos pad I'm
not sure exactly what he had or what it
was but all I know is I'm assuming
that's what it was because I'm not 100%
sure and then I went out and I was like
I got to I got to build something like
this so I I I used uh putty to stick it
to my Telecaster wild dude and a mini
cast bad it was awesome yeah dude it
worked so well I should I should do that
again you get a Luther to install one I
guarantee let's do it let's we we're
supposed to build a custom guitar let's
get a custom build with a touch pad in
it somebody hit me up about building
guitar and we just never got around yeah
they sent somebody sent one I'm not sure
if you customized it or anything but
they they sent a Guitar let's make it
happen I I don't know I defer to Carter
Carter you are in charge of music yeah
hit me
up all right we'll grab some more what
have we here kako says 99% of Pilots
agree with you but we don't know who's
in the back I only found out because I
asked who are the people with the
envelopes I suppose the issue
is you know let me just put it this way
if there's a pilot getting ready to take
off and then 20 people with envelopes
show up and that pilot says to the gate
agent hey who are these people with the
envelopes and they go those are illegal
immigrants he goes okay the plane's not
leaving they will remove those people
from the flight yeah the pilot does have
they do have like that kind of authority
don't they pilot just say off the plane
now yeah that's I don't care like if you
if you told me these people are being
trafficked they're not they're illegal
immigrants being trafficked just say I'm
not going to fly with those people on my
plane and that's it end of story it's
like I watch a video where a lady got
kicked off because she was arguing with
a flight attendant you mean to tell me
you can't kick off someone for being in
for for for for trying to be trafficked
I don't know that sounds like the
easiest way to get rid of you say you
need law enforcement to come in I mean I
someone could check this or whatever but
I do believe that the pilot has like
just like the captain of a ship the
captain of the of the plane has final
say if he says someone goes they go and
he's like the FL attendants have that
Authority that's what I think yeah I
think so it's not just that even if you
didn't have the authority you can be
like look boss I'm not flying a plane
I'm not going to be the guy trafficking
these people you know what I mean you
want you want someone to traffic
undocumented aliens and go to jail or
whatever you find somebody else to do it
but that's the thing here here's here's
here's here's what I what I see is
happening there'll be a lot of Pilots
will just be like if I just say nothing
no one will ever get mad at me and
they'll never know I did it yeah that
basically is saying y'all commit the
crime it's fine I'm getting a paycheck I
don't want to risk it I worked for a
company once nonprofit they sent us out
to fund ra we were doing Street
fundraising let me let me tell you a
story about a company I worked for when
deep water Horizon uh had the disaster
and oil was spilling they gave us these
pieces of paper with a fact sheet and I
went wow I believed the fact sheet and
so when I went out to uh I was on I
think I was on Sunset in Los Angeles I
was near the CNN building and near
Amoeba Music if you guys know amiea and
I was waving to people being like Hey
we're raising money we're building
awareness and we're advocating members
of Congress to enact Environmental
Policy here's our information we need
you to give us money and people were
like yes of course oh man deep water
Horizon that was so horrible that oil
spill I'm like right we need better
protections and then one guy came up to
me and he was like you're lying and I
said what do you mean that's not how
much oil is being spilled that's not
true and I was like what and I looked at
it and I forgot the it's been decade but
I was like it's been more than a decade
actually it's been like 12 years and I
was like uh no it's like 10,000 or he's
like no it isn't it's way less than that
and he was like I mean it's bad but
you're out here lying to people what are
you exaggerating so they give you money
and I was like I got to be honest man we
these are that our bosses give us these
fact cheats I we just I just assumed it
was true and he goes well it's not true
and you should stop lying to people and
I was like I agree and so I immediately
called the office and I said hey man the
fact sheets you gave us are wrong I'm
not going to lie to people to convince
them to give me money and they said well
we'll fix it but just keep working
anyway and I said no
and I that was it hung up went back and
said if you're going to tell me to lie
to people to get them to give me money
that's fraud I'm not going to do it and
they were like okay we'll fix it someone
tweeted at me saying Matt from Muse did
have the chaos pad it was a chaos pad
yeah cool I I didn't know exactly what
it was I just saw him playing once and I
assumed that's what it was and the
reason I'm careful to say it because it
may have been a different company or
something but he had like a touch thing
in it so I built one but anyway I
digress look man I ended up I ended up
uh let's just say that company in
dispute and that was one of the final
moments when they told me just keep
fundraising and I said I will not use I
will not lie to people for
money that's me you know you do you I
guess Chris lson says I backed the gold
Reserve but where is the reserve
kept yeah for
for they haven't given a good accounting
lately what's left in there if there's
any left you know at this point been
asking for that information well ladies
and gentlemen uh thank you so much for
for hanging out it's been a blast head
over to
timcast.net
uh as many primary events as possible so
we've got probably I I don't know if
we'll do super Tuesday because for March
we're planning this big Pittsburgh event
and uh we're hoping we can pull it off
it's not going to be very easy and the
reason is politicians are scared that's
right the people who are running for
president are terrified to enter an
arena where I say crazy things and uh
you know to to to put it much more
simply we've heard from a lot of people
who are in politics they don't actually
want to talk about topical news they
want to talk about controlled issues so
ask yourself this if you ever watch a
podcast and you're wondering at why a
major breaking story wasn't addressed
especially as it pertains to a certain
political candidate it's probably
because the candidate said I'll come on
your show as long as you don't talk
about X and then the podcast said okay
we'll do that we don't we tell people we
just pull up whatever's in the big
whatever's whatever's big in the news
there are certain things we will at
timcast agree we won't talk about if
someone comes on the show and they're
like I I don't want to talk about
religion I'm like oh I don't care like
we're here to talk about the news if you
don't talk about religion I'm not going
to bug you about religion but if you
come here and say oh did you hear about
that Epstein thing I don't want to bring
up the Epstein thing I'll be like well
that's the news so you're out of luck
but this means a lot of politicians
they're not going to want to do it but
uh so we got plans and uh because of you
guys as members those of you hang out
the Discord especially we are able to
budget effectively and make plans for
what we're going to do throughout the
year and we're going to do a bunch of
really really fun and crazy stuff the
the big goal is we're doing this thing
with vake in five days wof five days the
tickets that people bought for this show
they're not just sitting in an
auditorium looking up at a stage they're
going to be sitting on chairs probably
like 10 feet away from all of us and
we're going to ask questions and we're
going to hang out so it's it's much more
of a hangout than anything else which
means we got a lot lot of security we
got a lot of vetting it means some
tickets May get kicked back because you
know if some someone with nefar
nefarious intentions wants to come in
then we're going to push those to
somebody else but uh should be a lot of
fun you can follow the show at timcast
IRL you can follow me personally at
timcast uh rep Mooney do you want to
shout anything out oh gosh well shout
out to my wife and three kids for uh
sticking with the sticking with the
gentleman in politics but know thanks
for having me on the show thanks to Good
Old West Virginia for allowing me the
chance to represent them in Congress and
I'm running for the US Senate and Mooney
for wv.com is my website on Twitter x uh
just Mooney for WV and Mooney for rep I
think it's rep Alex Mooney is Twitter
handle I don't know man I people that do
that
stuff you worry about getting the gold
standard back you get the people to
worry about Twitter yeah SLX all right
right on thanks for hanging out Carter I
think it is rep Alex money cuz I I
searched it to make sure before tagged
you didn't want to tag the wrong one um
but I just want to say to everyone who
uh supported us with together again
thank you so much I spent the last two
weeks digging into exactly why only a
quarter of our sales they said were
going to be reported yeah uh weren't uh
this song did better than any of the
other ones and I biggest release ever
man you guys rock out out of five songs
but this one really hit and um I've seen
behind the curtain on how it's tracked
and I've become a savant on Billboard
charts at this point so we're getting
there let me it quick for everybody so
billboard decided they will no longer
count certain sales uh Direct Customer
sales so here's how it works you set up
your store what they're basically saying
is if you want to chart you have to go
through iTunes and Amazon big Tech owns
the space now yep so if you want to own
your own digital store for selling your
music you no longer get to be a part of
the of of the charting process this is
what what I was saying they want to try
and gatekeep and control it but it's the
hardest thing for them to do so they
play dirty games like this there's a
company called
Luminate they track all sales and
streams and premium streams it's a bunch
of different things they
track those numbers then get reported to
billboard the Luminate and the direct it
to customer companies there's three
companies so we sell our song you guys
buy it and they report the number to
luminate Luminate tracks and accumulates
all the data from all the different
platforms and gives it to billboard and
then billboard throws our views in the
trash and says we don't count those the
two companies in the front had no idea
that billboard was doing that it is a
dirty game but we're going to win so
hopefully we have the next song eyes of
advice out uh really soon as well as uh
I think we're calling it a hunger inside
really soon and then I think we're going
to we're going to try and get I don't
know how many songs that puts it'll put
us at for the album like eight I'm
working on trying to figure out what we
should put all on it but we'll
definitely have eight I think and then I
just started writing one today which is
but I'll keep close to the chest on this
one but I think uh we we'll end up with
like nine or 10 possibly because the
another thing I think we have to uh
record and figure out how to record
effectively as words in a book but that
should hit us that should be relatively
easy easier even though it's kind of a
hard hard song to record but then about
10 so yeah yeah yeah but anyway um it's
going to be great uh big plans for trash
house which you can follow at you just
go to trash house records.com uh it will
redirect you to the YouTube um if you
want to follow me personally just Carter
Banks or Carter banks on Twitter and um
yeah and also eyes of advice is the song
is done uh a hunger inside is it's done
but we're we're messing around with it
uh and then we've got potentially words
in a book and a new song I'm going to
write but these These are these are both
relatively simpler songs that shouldn't
take us that long and the reason I'm
saying this is because what I would
really prefer to do right now is finish
James O'Keefe's song more than anything
else but I feel like I don't want to
just it's it's been long enough we
should just put out the first album for
timcast before we start working on
james' stuff but then uh the other thing
we need to do is uh we need to hire more
Engineers to work under Carter so that
we can start ramping up the production
and bring on other artists and uh I I'm
really hoping we can get like two two
bands under the label that uh we can
find organically like new artists that
we can promote and stuff like that but I
actually I think I think we've got some
hits for James James has got some good
song ideas very talented guy I think the
stuff we produce with James o'keef and
the videos are gonna smash the records
uh I'm I mean break the records and
smash the charts so uh really excited
anyway Phil hi I am uh Phil that remains
on X or Twix I am Phil that remains
official on Instagram the band is All
That Remains you can follow us on
Spotify Apple music uh Amazon music
YouTube you know Pandora the
internet and uh I am surge.com again I
want to shout out uh homie suit and Tai
guy for sending me the record if anyone
makes dance music records send them to
me I make records and like records and
we'll play them for real if they're good
uh again promoting culture everything
like that so yeah well we'll we we'll
put out Serge of stuff too yeah that's
that's all there all right everybody you
got one more Twitter's Moody for WV
there you go good correction all right
everybody thanks for hanging out we'll
have Clips throughout the weekend and
we'll be back on
Monday